So, Leute wollen mir irgendwelche Dinge sagen. Ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Wir ignorieren das einfach. Hallo, hier ist die Freak Show. Herzlich Willkommen.
Prost.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich eine reguläre Ausgabe? Wollen wir das veröffentlichen
oder ist das geheim? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Das wird sich noch erweisen.
Denke ich. Das wird sich noch erweisen. Also es könnte die 301.
Folge der Freak Show sein.
Man munkelt noch, wie es genau sein wird.
Diese Dinge sind noch unklar. Aber wir sind hier auf dem 39C3 in so einem kleinen
Bütchen namens Sendezentrum Bühne.
Und ja, wir haben ganz viele tolle Gäste hier irgendwie. Hallo.
Sehr divers auch alle, vor allem so in den Farben.
Schlechtern und so. Ganz viele verschiedene Töne schwarz.
Alle Schattierungen von schwarz sind vertreten.
Nachtschwarz, Rabenschwarz.
Rabenschwarz, Nachtschwarz.
Kohlschwarz.
Ja, insofern, hallo, ich bin's Tim und das ist Roddy. Ihr kennt das schon,
das Spiel. Und Ralf ist auch dabei.
Einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Genau, und das sind wir. Und wir hatten uns ja überlegt, dass wir hier eine
kleine Sendung machen, obwohl ich ja immer so ein bisschen sendungsfaul bin, muss ich zugeben.
Und wir machen das heute mal alles total anders. Heute geht es nämlich um euch.
Wir werden euch jetzt noch mit etwas Geplänkel bei Laune halten und danach müsst
ihr euch mal scharf überlegen, ob die Sendung noch weiterlaufen soll.
Weil sie wird nicht weiterlaufen, wenn ihr nicht mitmacht. Das ist sozusagen das Ding.
Wir nennen das The Freak Show Clubhouse. Und das heißt, wir erinnern uns wehmütig
an die Corona-Zeit, die ja so schön war, die wir alle in bester Erinnerung haben.
Und wo ein Dienst auf einmal seine Chance bekam, die auch weitgehend verspielt hat, muss man sagen.
Warum eigentlich?
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage.
Das können wir nochmal diskutieren.
Können wir gerne diskutieren. Wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, Clubhouse war halt
so, oder ist eigentlich auch immer noch tatsächlich, so einen Audiodienst,
der, also man hatte halt die, oder kann auch immer noch starten,
die Clubhouse-App und dann konnte man so Räume aufmachen, indem man sich dann halt traf.
Und ich war ja damals relativ begeistert von Clubhouse. Wir haben das ja auch
für einige Formate dann, also für UKW vor allem benutzt, aber auch so noch ein
paar lustige Sachen gemacht,
weil Clubhouse ein Ding wirklich gut hinbekommen hat, nämlich diese Bühnensituation zu moderieren.
Anders als jetzt so reine Konferenzräume, wo dann immer alle durcheinander schreien
und man schnell sich irgendwelche Trolle einfängt.
gab es halt immer die Leute, die diese Räume aufgemacht haben und die waren dann quasi on stage.
Und alle anderen waren erstmal im Publikum und die Leute, die on stage sind oder die Leute, die,
Adminrechte hatten, genau, die durften dann Leute, die die Hand gehoben haben
und die gerne on stage wollen, on stage holen und dann durften die eben mit
den anderen mitquatschen, solange bis sie wieder rausgeschmissen wurden oder
freiwillig gegangen sind.
Das ist eigentlich die ganze Essenz dessen.
Die Startphase war extrem restriktiv, habe ich in Erinnerung.
Man brauchte dann wieder so ominöse Invite-Codes, so ähnlich wie dann bei Blue
Sky und ob man es dann reingeschafft hat oder nicht.
Und ob man dann irgendwie alle paar Wochen konnte man dann einen neuen Invite-Code
bekommen und konnte andere Leute reinholen. Das war alles sehr….
War man ein Cool-Kit oder nicht?
Ja, und dann war es irgendwann komplett vorbei, nach gefühlt einem halben Jahr.
Dreiviertel Jahr. Bevor es vorbei war, also bevor es gefühlt vorbei war,
wie gesagt, der Dienst gibt es noch.
Dann haben sie erstmal ein paar Sachen verbessert und später haben sie dann
ein paar Sachen verschlechtert.
Es wurde dann total kompliziert, dann gab es nicht irgendwie nur Räume,
sondern dann konnte man auch ein...
Haus aufmachen und dann haben sich alle gefragt, was genau ist denn jetzt eigentlich ein Haus?
Und um es noch so richtig kompliziert zu machen, konnte man später auch Clubs aufmachen.
Also es gab ein Clubhaus, Hauses und Clubs und keiner wusste jetzt so richtig
genau, was eigentlich, wie, was, wann ist es?
Aber vom Namen her.
Nicht so schlecht. Haben sie irgendwie alles was beigedacht.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, wüsstest du jetzt intuitiv, was ein Club und was
ein Haus ist und wo so der Unterschied ist?
Also ein Haus besteht aus mehreren Räumen. das,
dürfte das Setup gewesen sein und ein Club besteht wahrscheinlich so aus einem
großen Partybereich und dann so verschiedenen Rückzugsorten wo dann das Licht
gedämmt ist und Dinge passieren so.
Das hast du jetzt gesagt so ein Audio Darkroom wäre mal eine interessante Sache,
da müssen sich wahrscheinlich alle demonstrativ anschweigen oder sowas oder
ist dann nur Gebärdensprache im Einsatz,
ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau naja, auf jeden Fall das war sozusagen Clubhouse und später,
es wurde natürlich dann schlimm, denn wie immer, wie ist das so,
nach einer Weile kamen dann erstmal so die Schwurbler,
Weil es war ja auch Corona und dann gab es dann halt so Schwobler,
da dachte man schon so, oh Mann.
Dann kamen irgendwie die Prolls, das fand ich am unerträglichsten.
Dann kamen Leute, die irgendwelche Finanz-Spam-Geschichten da breitgetreten
haben mit tausenden von Followern.
Oh ja, ja.
Ja, werde reich in zwei Wochen mit diesen zehn Finanztipps.
Also alles, was du halt so auf Insta findest, sagen wir mal.
Ja, genau. Also einfach der ganze Dreck der Realität war dann halt da auch und
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, hat es dann keinen Spaß mehr gemacht und als dann alle
wieder in einen normalen Club gehen durften, verlief das so ein bisschen im Sande.
Wobei ich sagen muss, es gibt tatsächlich auch immer noch Leute,
die dort Angebote machen, seit Anfang an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das für die funktioniert, also teilweise so Nachrichten und so.
Aber wofür ich es richtig gut fand, waren so Feedback-Gründen.
Also wir haben das ja für UKW dann gemacht, das heißt wir haben immer die Sendung
rausgehauen, also damals, als wir noch diese regelmäßigen Corona-Sendungen hatten und dann,
naja, hat das wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Menge Fragen beantwortet,
aber weitere aufgerissen und dann haben wir halt gesagt, so hier drei Tage nach
Sendungsveröffentlichung machen wir nochmal so eine Feedback-Runde und dann
war halt so Fragestellen und da funktionierte das halt auch alles ziemlich gut.
Also das fand ich irgendwie total toll.
Ja, soviel zu Clubhouse. Und das ist hier sozusagen auch unser Modell.
Das heißt, ihr könnt dann irgendwann die Hand heben und sagen,
ich habe jetzt ein Thema für euch, weil wir haben nämlich nichts vorbereitet.
Nicht, dass wir das sonst tun würden, aber hier leben wir das jetzt einfach
mal so demonstrativ aus.
Aber wir haben genug Kanäle.
Wie genug Kanäle? Für was?
Habt ihr schon Chaos-Bild gelesen?
Nein.
Nein, gibt es nämlich hier. Chaos-Bild. Ist an verschiedenen Outlets zu haben,
habe ich gehört, im Späti.
Und steht das hier eigentlich, wo das noch verbreitet wird? Das stand irgendwie
auf der Webseite oder irgendwo so.
Auflösung in der nächsten Ausgabe. Es wird noch mehrere Ausgaben geben.
Und genau. Das hier so ein bisschen, bin mir nicht ganz so sicher,
ob man das so ernst nehmen soll.
Was denn hier? Topfschlagen im Minenfeld. Das ist hier immer am Pingen der Zeit.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Und hier, guck mal, willst du mal die Hauptmeldung lesen?
Kann denn Kulinarik Sünde sein?
Nein, das ist die Hauptmeldung.
Das ist oben drin in dem Held.
Achso, Absage an ICC Berlin bis auf Saal 1.
Nee, du musst alles lesen. Ganz oben, da fängt es an. Kongress Koryphäe.
Nein, oben. Oben ist oben.
40 C3-Location.
Ja, jetzt findest du langsam den Einstieg ins Thema.
Das ist auch nicht barrierefrei gedruckt.
Nein, das ist nicht.
Kongresskorrifäe Britler äußert sich. Absage an ICC Berlin bis auf Saal 1 alles elend.
Das ist die Meldung.
Beziehungsweise zu klein. Darauf kann man sich einigen, oder?
Aber auch Saal 1 ist zu klein eigentlich.
Ja. ja.
Gibt es dann aber auch ein, lesen Sie weiter auf Seite 4 oder ist das wirklich nur die Überschrift?
Naja, Seite 4 wird schwierig. Ja, ja.
Die Seite 4.
Es sind ja nur zwei.
Ja, es fehlt der Content.
Ich bin froh, dass es keine Seite 3 gibt, weil ihr wisst ja,
was auf Seite 3 normalerweise auch einwartet.
Achso, der Ticket unten drunter gehört direkt dazu.
Ja, genau. Es ist so vom Layout her noch ein bisschen überarbeitet. Hardware?
Ja.
So ein Naked Machines.
Mhm.
Du musst das jetzt nicht alles lesen. Ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen,
dass es mittlerweile auch ein Chaos-Bild gibt und so weiter.
Und die scheint den Finger am Puls der Zeit zu haben.
Chaos-Bild. Demnächst in eurer Inbox. So.
Kongress, Ralf. Du wolltest noch was zum Kongress sagen.
Ja, ich bin wieder mit Kindern hier. Was nach wie vor ein schöner Perspektivwechsel ist.
Leute, die auch mit ihren Kids hier sind, die können das, glaube ich,
nachvollziehen. Das ist ja ein sehr anderer Kongress, den man so erlebt, aber auch sehr schön.
Ich habe mich aber gestern Abend dann mal losgeeist und mich in die 50 Minuten
Warteschlange vor Marc-Uwe Kling reinbegeben und mir meinen Platz in Saal 1.
Kämpfen wir kurz in die Rolle. War jemand von euch da gestern?
50 Prozent.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Für die Eltern unter euch, Marc-Uwe Kling, Erfinder des Ninehorns,
so eins der bekanntesten Kinderbücher der letzten Jahre. Nein!
Und den Älteren unter uns, davor vielleicht eher bekannt von den epischen Känguru-Chroniken.
Habt ihr die gelesen, gehört?
Nein, ihr kennt das immer noch nicht.
Das solltet ihr aber mal tun.
Ich weiß.
Das ist schon eine der besseren deutschen Humorgeschichten. Also ernsthaft.
Und der war schon immer sehr politisch und sozial engagiert,
eigentlich auch mit seinem Känguru.
Das Känguru ist eigentlich eher so kommunistisch, nidinistisch angehaucht.
Und arbeitet auch schon immer im Sinne der Weltrevolution. Und gestern jetzt
aus dem neuen Buch, dem neuen Känguru-Buch vorgelesen.
Und das wird einen klaren Schwerpunkt haben auf digitale Souveränität und Entschittification
und militärisch-industrieller US-Komplex und was man dort eigentlich gegen tun kann.
Und da war ich gestern mit dabei und habe mir das angehört und fand es in der Tat ganz vorzüglich.
Der ist ja auch Gründungsmitglied bei uns von der Safe Social Kampagne.
Und der hat dann gestern mit Linus zusammen den Digital Independence Day ausgeschrieben
oder verkündet, den wir uns ausgedacht hatten.
Und den wollte ich hier einmal zumindest kurz pitchen.
Der Gedanke dahinter ist relativ einfach. Wir alle, und ich glaube wirklich
vermutlich wir alle, wie wir hier in dem Raum sind,
haben mindestens einen, vermutlich aber zu viele verschiedene Accounts immer
noch bei problematischen Netzwerken, weil es ist halt so bequem und man ist
dann doch irgendwie nie, hatte nie die Zeit, irgendwas zu wechseln.
Und der Gedanke von diesem Digital Independence Day ist, jeden ersten Sonntag
im Monat setzt man sich mal ein halbes Stündchen hin und migriert genau einen dieser Accounts.
Das heißt also, wenn man immer noch was auf X hat, dann geht man halt vielleicht mal rüber zu Mastadon.
Oder wenn man immer noch was auf Instagram macht, dann geht man vielleicht zu
Pixelfed. Oder wenn man noch ein Google Docs hat, wo man immer viel mit Tabellen
macht, überlegt man, ob man es zu Kollaborer rüber reitet und so weiter und so fort.
Und es reicht also so eine Migration pro Sonntag und pro Monat und dann gibt
man damit an, dass man es getan hat.
Und es wird sich auch lokal hoffentlich was organisieren, so wie damals Crypto-Partys
hat es ja auch ganz viel gegeben, dass daraus dann also wirklich so eine etwas
breitere Bewegung wird. so, wir greifen euch unter die Arme und wir helfen euch.
So, und da gibt es auch eine schöne Produktseite zu, die iDay, so von I Did It.
Abgeleitet und dort findet man dann beispielsweise schöne Rezepte,
so wirklich im Sinne von Kochrezepten.
So, ich will jetzt also von X zu Mastodon wechseln.
Wie geht denn das eigentlich? Das ist auch ein schönes Artwork,
was wir hier dazu haben. Dann sehen wir jetzt hier ein schönes Keks.
Endlich kann ich mal sagen, jetzt sehen wir hier und wir sehen das auch wirklich in diesem Podcast.
Ja, aber nur die da.
Ja, weil die anderen sehen es ja in der Videoaufzeichnung.
Gibt es eine Videoaufzeichnung?
Das hoffe ich doch, oder?
Nee. Ja? Ich bin gar nicht geschminkt.
Kameras und alle sowas. Jetzt sehen wir hier tote Twitter-Vögel mit toten Augen
und stattdessen ein fröhliches blaues Mastodon.
Und unten drunter steht dann also das Rezept wirklich mit Zubereitung und wie
schwierig ist es, das zu kochen.
Und man dann also sehen kann und an die Hand genommen wird, so kannst du diesen
einen Dienst jetzt rüber migrieren. Das finde ich doch eine sehr schöne Aktion.
Mal gucken, ob das Ganze ordentlich Momentum aufgibt.
Und das Wichtige ist aber, dass man damit angibt, dass die Restwelt also auch
mitbekommt, so man hat es getan und das tut man natürlich bevorzugt auf einem
freien Netzwerk seiner Wahl und hier habe ich schon mal eine Masterwall zusammengebaut
unter den entsprechenden Hashtags,
das wären dann I did it oder dude gemacht oder Digital Independence Day und
das fühlt sich schon fröhlich, obwohl noch überhaupt nicht der vierte erste
ist, was der nächste Sonntag dann wäre, wo wir das machen.
Er füllt sich schon mit Erfolgsmeldungen, weil man kann natürlich auch schon
dort posten, was man bisher schon alles migriert hat.
Gemäß dem Credo, es gibt nichts Gutes, außer man tut es. Man muss einfach mal loslegen.
Das scheint mir eine hilfreiche Geschichte zu sein. Und guckt euch wirklich
auch nochmal diesen Talk an. Das wird ja wie üblich alles aufgezeichnet. Hier Saal 1.
Das war auch wirklich ein ganz blendender Vortrag, den er da gehalten hat.
Das lohnt sich unbedingt.
Das war sehr adressatengerecht. alles total IT fixiert.
Ja, das war das Schöne, was ich bisher vom Kongress mitgebracht hatte.
Ansonsten habe ich das Balloon Operation Center gestartet.
Oh, was für eine Art Ballons.
Ja, warte mal.
Nicht mit Helium, oder?
Nein, darüber haben wir schon diskutiert, das muss ich gar keinen Fall machen.
Mal gucken, ob ich das hier auf die Seite werfen kann. Nee, nicht so wirklich.
Wie kann ich denn jetzt hier meine Bildschirmfreigabe ändern?
Bildschirmfreigabe.
Grübel, grübel. Aber warte mal, machen wir doch einfach, wenn wir schon hier...
Das ist wieder so visuell hier im Podcast, das führt immer ins Verderben.
Ach naja, so da haben wir es. So, das 39C3 Balloon Operation Center.
Das findet sich im Kidspace jeden Tag um 16 Uhr, mache ich das mit einem Kollegen zusammen.
Und wir haben 800 Ballons mit, davon sind jetzt ungefähr so die Hälfte verballert,
aber für morgen ist also noch ordentlich was da.
und der Gedanke ist, dass man dort mal wieder etwas lernt, was man vorher so
nicht konnte, aber vielleicht irgendwie immer faszinierend fand und nie so sich
getraut hat, das da mal wirklich auszuprobieren, nämlich so komplexere Ballon-Tiere
basteln, so aus diesen Modellier-Ballons.
Und da ist ein QR-Code mit drauf, wo eine Videosammlung von mir ist,
also nicht mit Videos von mir, sondern wo ich ein bisschen rumgesucht habe,
was sind gute Erklärungen.
Dann hast du da so 40 verschiedene Viecher, 40 nicht, 10 oder so Viecher,
die man nachkneten und nachbauen kann und dann merkt man, okay,
wenn man erstmal die Angst überwunden hat, so einen Ballon,
hart ranzunehmen und das tut gar nicht weh und die sind halt,
wenn man gute Profimodellier- Ballons hat, die gehen einfach mal nicht kaputt.
Das heißt also egal, was du mit denen knetest, die halten einfach.
Und das dachte ich, das passt gut hier auf den Kongress, um mal wieder Eltern für ihre nächste Party.
Jetzt gibt es auch Raketenballons oder Ballonraketen.
Genau, diese Rakete, die sind schon etwas komplexer, aber es geht auch.
Das sind also vier oder fünf Ballons dann zusammengebaut. Da dachte ich ja,
so eine Fairy Dust passt dir auch gut hin. Kann man auch machen.
Sieht aber auch schon so ein bisschen aus, als könnte es von der AI ausgefiltert werden.
Das ist auch AI-generiert, natürlich. Das ist nicht die echte Anleitung,
aber unter dem QR-Code kriegt man die echte Anleitung für quasi eine Fairy Dust-Rakete.
Und das ist ganz lustig. Morgen machen wir das nochmal, 16 bis 17 Uhr,
schaut vorbei. Dinge lernen, dafür sind wir hier.
So, Roddy, und womit beschäftigst du dich? Du hast hier ein blinkendes T-Shirt.
Ja, das… Wie viel sind das?
16 mal 16.
Okay.
Und übrigens, es ist nicht hell. Das ist hell.
Okay, also das Ding ist einfach unter das Shirt gehängt und nicht ins Shirt.
Ja, ich nenne es ein Proof of Concept. Ich habe mit ein bisschen Heißkleber
hier operiert und habe das alles auf ein altes T-Shirt draufgeklebt.
Okay. Die Ansteuerung ist so ein Ding, was bei einem der LEDs mit dabei war.
Also es ist jetzt keine Schöpfungshöhe bis jetzt.
Du machst so Hardware-Bastel.
Ja, aber mache ich ja gerne mal so für und auf dem Kongress.
Okay.
Ja, so, ich hoffe, ihr habt euch langsam was überlegt, sonst ist die Sendung nicht mehr lang.
Wo ist die erste Hand?
Da, ist die erste Hand.
Die Hand im grünen Chart.
Genau, wir haben einen Gast. Applaus, Applaus.
So, das aufsetzen, dann Moin sagen. So.
Moin.
Moin, hallo. Wen haben wir denn jetzt hier bei uns?
Wir haben den Arne.
Herzlich willkommen, Arne.
Und ich habe einen Adapter mitgebracht.
Ein Adapter. Dank des Adapters.
Sehr gut.
Endlich. Ich wusste schon gar nicht, wie wir die Verbindung herstellen sollen hier.
Wie wir sehen, handelt es sich um einen Adapter von Schuko-Stecker auf Doppel-Euro.
Ja, sehr praktisch.
Wofür?
Warum habe ich den immer dabei beim Reisen? Das ist die Frage.
Früher hätte man gesagt, für deinen Rasierapparat. Aber ich glaube,
die Zeit ist dann vorbei.
Naja, ich meine, also ich verstehe die Frage nicht so ganz genau.
Ich meine, das ist doch ganz praktisch, wenn man, also das ist sozusagen,
du meinst beim Reisen mit der Bahn, weil es dann nur einen Schuko-Stecker gibt,
aber für zwei Sitze? Fast?
Die umständig kaputt sind in letzter Zeit. Ich sitze ständig in in Eisenbahnwagen.
Die haben Wackelkontakt.
Und dann der ganze Wagen vor allen Dingen.
Das ist nur beim ICE 4 der Fall.
Ja, und der hilft.
Sehr, sehr, der hilft. Denn diese Handylader, die passen ja sowieso nicht zwei Stück rein.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist nur der Adapter, damit der nicht so rumwackelt.
Das?
Denn diese Euro-Stecker, da bist du dann die ganze Zeit so am Festhalten während
der Fahrt, um so ein ganz bisschen Ladung zu bekommen, lässt es los und dann… Ja.
Das ist in der Tat ein absolut valider Lifehack, hervorragend. Super.
Aber also deine These ist, dass…,
Das wirklich nur Wackelkontakte sind, weil also ich habe wirklich letzte Woche
in einem ICE gesessen, ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Vierer war,
und der komplette Wagen, sämtliche Steckdosen funktionierten nicht.
Und das war mir zu unwahrscheinlich zu sagen, das ist alles Wackelkontakt.
Achso, nee, das kann was anderes sein. Also was ich meine ist,
du hast ja einen Euro-Stecker, meist so für die ganzen Handys,
und du hast den Schuko-Stecker.
Und der Schuko-Stecker hat ja auch weitere Pinöppel.
Oh, das stimmt. Ja, die Pinöppel sind ein bisschen breiter.
Habt ihr mal einen Euro-Stecker da?
Zum Vergleich.
Keinen, den ich jetzt hier rausziehen will.
Ja, ich glaube schon. Jetzt gucken wir doch mal, ob das auch alles stimmt,
was hier so behauptet wird.
Ah, da ist einer. Ja, guck mal, der passt hier sowieso nicht mit einem anderen
noch rein. Aber, ihr seht.
Ja, die sind ein bisschen dünner.
Die sind definitiv dünner.
Okay.
Ja.
Ralf, willst du erstmal hier Realitätscheck vornehmen?
Das sehe ich aber sogar schon.
Hier adaptiere doch mal.
Das ist signifikant.
Ja, das ist signifikant.
Damals.
Hast du mal nachgemessen oder kennst du die Specs?
Nee, leider nicht.
Guck mal, schon hat sich die Sendung gewohnt. Hervorragend.
Fährt denn einer von euch regelmäßig Bahn?
Regelmäßig ist ein großes Wort, aber ich...
Das hängt sehr stark von der Bahn ab, würde ich sagen.
Nicht regelmäßig, aber wenn, dann sehr intensiv. Im Sinne, dass ich dann meine
beiden Racker dabei habe und wenn da das iPad leer ist, dann ist das Drama groß.
Bitte schön, fang. Dann ist das was für dich.
Ich hab zwei von denen dabei.
Geschenke.
Kannst du gerne mit Unterschrift hinterher noch drauf machen.
Ja, ich habe noch einen zweiten dabei, den lasse ich von dir unterschreiben.
Welchen sehr in Ihren?
Von dir will ich da die unterschreiben.
Cool, was machst du sonst so, Anne? Ja, Bahnfahren. Achso, bist du der Typ,
der mit der Bahncard 100, der da wohnt?
Nee, das nicht.
Okay, aber du bist gezwungen, Bahn zu fahren oder machst du das tatsächlich gerne?
Das mache ich tatsächlich gerne und weit. Also nach Osteuropa oder so, das ist ja schön billig.
Da habe ich meinen Verspätungsrekord gebrochen. Ich glaube, fünfeinhalb Stunden
waren das. Nachzug in Rumänien. Aber du hast halt dein Hotelzimmer dabei.
Das ist ja scheißegal.
Musst du nur die Pläne so ein bisschen ändern. Dann habe ich der rumänischen
Eisenbahn geschrieben, weil es ja EU-Recht und Verspätungskompensation.
Dann sagten die, ja, die Richtlinie gilt auch in Rumänien, aber nicht für Verspätung.
Sondern für Entgleisung.
Ich weiß es nicht. zwei Tage später bin ich mit dem Zug dann von Rumänien nach
Ungarn gefahren und an der gleichen Nacht ist ein anderer Zug auf anderer Strecke
gefahren und der ist entgleist.
Aber nur so ein paar Meter vor dem Bahnhof in Budapest. Da habe ich dann gelesen,
dass die Fahrgäste da eine halbe Stunde drin saßen, irgendwann keine Geduld
mehr haben und sind so halt zu Fuß über die Gleise mit ihrem Kram.
Und wir wurden dann um sieben Uhr morgens irgendwo mitten in in Ungarn,
in Püschpökladani oder so, rausgeschmissen und da ist es, ja,
ihr hättet zwar noch zwei Stunden schlafen können, aber jetzt ist sieben Uhr,
in fünf Minuten halten wir, bitteschön.
Hier fahren irgendwelche Züge nach Budapest. Wir lassen jetzt keine ausländischen
Züge mehr rein, weil Bahnchaos, ein rumänischer Zug ist.
Entgleist. Ah, okay, verstehe, oh Mann. Das heißt, du machst das ganz viel so
durch Europa fahren? Ja. Okay.
Und ist das dann, keine Ahnung, machst du dann Interrail oder ist das irgendwie?
Interrail nur im Westen von Europa. Da lohnt sich das.
Und dann gibt es, im Osten ist sowieso zu billig. Also das lohnt sich nicht,
ein Interrail-Ticket zu kaufen.
Und das ist auch Teil der Herausforderung, zu schauen, wie kann ich die Tickets überhaupt buchen.
Ja, das ist… Also habe ich so herausgefunden, dass es für Rumänien einen IT-Dienstleister
gibt, der die IT für die ganzen Bahnunternehmen macht und der so eine Meta-Plattform
hat, wo man alle Informationen kriegt.
zu den vier verschiedenen Betreibern und das ist dann, also die Vorbereitung
der Reise dauert fast genauso lang wie die Reise selbst.
So mit ganz großen Exklusiv-Abergen.
Inklusive Verspätung dann. Okay. Aha. Und dann, also bist du jetzt so ein,
wie nennt man die Leute, die immer Bahn fahren? Haben die nicht so einen Namen?
Bahnfahrer?
Ne, ja.
Leider.
Ich habe das gleich mit Trainspottern verwechselt.
Da gibt es ja so einen Term. Aber also bist du so ein, also würdest du dich
als Bahn-Nerd bezeichnen? Ja.
Ich wurde da angefixt von so einem Trainfluencer.
Oh. Von wem? Von John Wurst oder?
Nee, der Peter Leskai.
Alle sagen ja, okay, dann klär mich mal auf. Okay, glaube ich noch nicht.
Der fährt Regionalzüge aus Ulm heraus.
Wow, jetzt bin ich schon.
Ja, es geht los. Ein bisschen aufgerübt.
Nee, der macht so,
Hochformat-Videoschnipsel.
Für junge Leute sozusagen.
Aber auch lange Hochformat-Videoschnipsel. Wo dann so Sachen erklärt werden,
wie diese Nummern am Zug, was bedeuten die?
Oder warum fährt der so langsam hier in den Bahnhof ein? Will der mich ärgern?
Und so ist das dann langsam eskaliert. dass man sich so Fragen stellt wie,
Warum heißt das eigentlich D-Zug?
Ich weiß es, ich will sagen, ich will sagen, Durchgangszug.
Weil man da nämlich durchgehen kann und die Wagen nicht voneinander getrennt sind.
Nicht wie im Wilden Westen, wo man dann auf so einen Balkon geht und dann rüberspringen
muss auf den nächsten oder so.
Gut, ne? Das ist ja eine Spice. Du bist ja auch ein Schwächner.
Naja, einfach nur so ein Nerd halt.
Ich habe eigentlich ein gutes Verhältnis zu Zügen. Es wurde allerdings in den
letzten Jahren etwas ramponiert, wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt,
weil es läuft ja alles nicht mehr so gut und da ich ja auch mal eine Weile mit
Bahncard 100 unterwegs war und da,
sozusagen das Leben in voll Zügen genießen konnte,
ja, speziell halt Nachtzüge, aber dann bin ich halt irgendwie wirklich mental
komplett zusammengebrochen, als dann die Bahn so diese,
Nachtzüge hat so verrotten lassen, wirklich jedes Jahr wurde es immer schlimmer
und dann haben sie ja immer gesagt,
ich habe überhaupt keinen Bock mehr und dann war dann irgendwie auch so bei
mir die Motivation irgendwie raus und ich verstehe ohnehin nicht,
warum wir nicht viel, viel, viel, viel, viel mehr Nachtzüge haben.
Das ist absurd, aber naja, das ist kaputt.
Pack mal gerade auf den Beamer die Nachtzugkarte.
Nachtzugkarte.
Da gibt es zwei oder Night Train Europe, es gibt so zwei Karten,
sind ungefähr gleich. Da sind alle Nachtzugverbindungen drin.
Genau. Guten Morgen Europa.
Sehr schön designt. Kann man sich so einen Überblick verschaffen,
wo man überall hinfahren kann.
Kannst du das mal so ein bisschen in unsere Richtung auch.
Ralf. Ja, es fehlte irgendwie ein Monitor.
Ja, es fehlte ein Monitor.
Also Wien ist so ein bisschen das Nachtzugzentrum von Europa.
Ja, wenig überraschend.
Wenn du einmal auf Wien über Wien rüber hauverst, dann siehst du,
wo es hingeht. Das ist wirklich gut verbunden. Auch hier von Hamburg,
da fahren dann die neuen Nachtzüge,
Aktuell noch mit einer vorgespannten Lok, weil der Steuerwagen nicht zugelassen ist.
Stimmt, davon habe ich auch gehört. Oh Mann, ey.
Beim ICEL ist der aber auch noch nicht zugelassen. Da fahren jetzt auch andere Züge andere Loks.
Da fahren dann beim ICL sogar die Siemens-Loks dran.
Was natürlich peinlich ist, weil das ja eigentlich ein spanisches Produkt ist.
Aber die Spanier haben auch ihre Loks noch nicht zugelassen.
Genau, die Loks. Der Rest schon, aber die Loks noch nicht, habe ich auch gelesen.
Nee, die Zulassung ist wohl generell schwierig von so Sachen.
Was auch gerade richtig, richtig hart nervt, sind die Erhöhungen der Sitzreservierungsgebühren.
Wo du jetzt für eine vierköpfige Familie mittlerweile wie viel? 24, 28 Euro?
Vorher konntest du eine Familienreservierung machen.
Jetzt zahlst du mittlerweile für die euren Sitzreservierungen mehr als für die Karten selber gefühlt.
Da habe ich auch noch einen Trick. Wenn eure Fernverkehrsverbindung aus nur
einem ICE besteht, dann könnt ihr sparen, indem ihr die Reservierung über die
tschechische Bahn bucht.
Und dann?
Ja, dann hast du die tschechische Reservierung. Kannst du keinen Komfort-Check-In
machen, das sind dann aber 75 Kronen, das ist so ein bisschen billiger.
Und du fährst aber innerhalb von Deutschland? Ach was.
Die CD, tschechische Bahn.
Wie viel sind denn 75 Kronen?
Das ist, ich glaube, so drei Euro.
Okay, das lohnt sich.
Drei Euro neun, ja.
Ja, also je nach Wechselkurs. Wenn man allerdings zwei Züge auf der Verbindung
hat, dann kostet jeder Zug einzeln.
Dann lohnt sich das wieder, ja, so gerade so nicht mehr.
Okay.
Oben kannst du auch auf Englisch umstellen. Aber ich meine, das ist auch schön auf Tschechisch.
Man lernt ja gerne dazu.
Ja, aber da gibt es auch eine schöne App von den Tschechen, da kann man sogar
einen Offline-Fahrplan speichern.
Interessant das Englisch, was wir gerade sehen.
Aber warte mal, was kostet denn jetzt die Reservierung neu, was ist denn jetzt
der Preis für eine Reservierung?
So 5,90 Euro in der zweiten Klasse und ich glaube 6,90 Euro in der ersten.
Ich reserviere kaum deswegen.
Außer über die Tschechen. Also man spatzt die Hälfte immerhin. Das ist ja cool.
Und die kann man sogar noch bis vor Abfahrt stornieren.
Also man kann sogar fies sein und sich was reservieren, schnell stornieren und
dann ist der wahrscheinlich fies. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht gemacht.
Mich hat aber auch leider noch niemand nach meiner Reservierungsbestätigung
gefragt. Sonst hätte ich gerne meine Reservatschi da vorgezeigt.
Aber es steht richtig dran. Also es ist so auf dem Display zu sehen.
Ja, man hat auch einen Code, diesen Aztek-Code da, der abgescannt werden kann und alles.
Es gibt einen Code für Reservierungen?
Nee, aber für Bahntickets. Das ist ja kein QR-Code, das ist ja so ein Aztek-Code.
Da gab es auch mal einen Talk vor ein paar Jahren, was da alles drinsteckt.
Ja.
Aber der ist auch ein bisschen proprietary.
Ich finde jetzt hier keine Verbindung. Was mache ich falsch?
Also ich will jetzt nach Berlin-Hamburg, Donnerstag 1.1. ab 19.04.
Ja, suchen unten rechts.
Dann passiert gar nichts. Wahrscheinlich glaubt ihr wieder nicht auf dem Safari.
Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Werbeblocker oder so.
So voll die Seuche.
Ja, also ich kann die App empfehlen, da geht das.
Da muss man dann umstellen auf nur Reservierung und dann, wahrscheinlich sind
das so Uraltverträge, die die europäischen Bahnen untereinander haben,
dass sie dann irgendwie zu so einem Alttarif noch Sachen buchen können.
Das ist jetzt auch so der neue Trend, irgendwie die ganzen Apps werden jetzt
nur noch als Webseiten gemacht, aber dann funktionieren sie als Webseiten nicht
mehr und nur noch als App.
Das ist irgendwie, da hast du wirklich das Schlechteste von beiden Seiten,
das ist eine Katastrophe.
Okay, also Chrom funktioniert auch nicht. Naja, man wird das irgendwie lösen.
Und sonst so, wenn du nicht Bahn fährst, was machst du dann?
Ich habe Biologie studiert und arbeite in der IT.
Ja, war die richtige Entscheidung, IT studieren, das ist ja unstrengend.
Okay, und wie lange bist du schon auf dem Kongress?
Das ist mein dritter Kongress. In Folge.
Kein Vor-Corona-Kongress.
Wie war das so?
Kongresse? Ja, das ist cool. Nur diesmal leider ein bisschen kleinere Crew.
Wir haben keine Tickets bekommen.
Ich habe dann auf dem Aftermarket noch was ergattert.
Tatsächlich? Auf der offiziellen Seite?
Ja, ja, sicher. Ja,
ja, sicher.
Natürlich.
Da war ein Logo drauf.
Ja, es ist schön, aber die Crew fehlt.
Also Grüße gehen raus an die Crew. Ja, das ist in der Tat ein Problem.
Also letztes Jahr hat sich hier so auf den letzten Metern eigentlich noch für
alle was ergeben, hatte ich so den Eindruck, aber diesmal war es ja schon wirklich
ein bisschen ja, weiß ich nicht, also das ein emotionales Drama,
was sich da entspannt hat.
Hier nicken auch schon alle, also ihr seid auch alle alleine hier, ne?
Aber es ist auch mal echt voll.
Neue Freunde finden, sorry.
Aber also das muss man die Location hier ist schon jetzt auch wirklich voll.
Also mehr kriegst du hier auch echt nicht rein.
Aber da sind da nicht noch 20 Messehallen nebenan. Aber es wäre unpraktisch,
ne? Na gut, haben wir dann geklärt.
Ich meine, das ist ja diese 40C3 Diskussion, so es ist halt immer wieder Fragestellungen
mit irgendwie wo könnte denn mehr Platz sein, aber ich weiß nicht, also so Messehallen.
Wie viele sind jetzt? 14.000 oder 16.000 hier?
Ich kann dir ehrlich gesagt nicht genau sagen, was der Cap ist.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist jemand? 16.000.
Okay. Unterkante, Oberlippe.
Ich glaube, das waren so 8.000 Telefonnummern, die registriert wurden beim POC.
Also in Leipzig waren es auch nur, ich glaube, 2.000 mehr. Das macht jetzt den Kohl nicht fett.
Also es sind natürlich 2.000 mehr, gar keine Frage, aber ich habe so die Vermutung, dass die Nachfrage,
größer ist. Warum auch immer, was finden eigentlich alle an dieser Veranstaltung,
dass die so oversubscribed ist?
Das ist einfach eine coole Welt.
Hast du den Kongress dir vorher, also ich meine, seit wann wusstest du denn,
dass es einen Kongress gibt und seit wann hast du den quasi verfolgt oder war
das dann sozusagen auch vor drei Jahren?
Ich würde mal sagen, der erste, wo ich eine Zahl nennen könnte,
wäre wahrscheinlich der 36C3. Also noch nicht so lange dabei.
Ja, aber immer mal wieder. Vorher wusstest du gar nicht.
Dass es das gibt.
Ja, ich wusste, dass es diese spannenden Vorträge gibt. So David Kriesel,
wenn er mal wieder einen Kopierer gehackt hat oder was auch immer.
Die Klassiker.
Aber ich wusste nicht, dass das so gemütlich ist alles.
Ich dachte, das wäre einfach nur so eine Halle, wo sonst so,
keine Ahnung, Parteitage stattfinden. Und dann sitzen die da alle und fertig.
Da wolltest du unbedingt hin, ja?
oder hat dir das dann einer verkehrt?
Ich habe dann irgendwann realisiert, das ist ja in Hamburg und ich komme nicht
weit weg von hier und gerade über Weihnachten.
Da kann man dann über den Regionalzug über Ulm eigentlich schnell anreisen.
Ich fahre nur mit meinem Lieblings-Lokführer, ETF.
Und mit tschechischer Reservierung?
Ja, nee, das geht. Also in der Regionalbahn, die meisten kann man ja gar nicht reservieren.
Aber ist Bescheid. Definitiv.
Man kann ihn nicht.
Okay.
Alright, Arne, das war super. Dein Applaus.
Danke euch. Schönen Kongress noch.
Toller Stecker irgendwie. Jetzt wisst ihr alle, wie ihr die Bahn bekämpfen könnt.
Also ich hatte tatsächlich dieses Problem mit den Steckern auch schon.
Ich werde das ausprobieren und bescheiden.
Ja, ja, das ist in der Tat eine wirklich gute Idee. Ja, wir machen mal weiter.
Los. Wer hat das nächste Thema? Ihr müsst jetzt einen Schwank aus eurem Leben
hier beitragen, sonst ist die Sendung vorbei. Dann war es das.
Alles für die Katz.
Ihr seid nicht mal mehr der Erste.
Ja, genau.
Einen der Herbst schwarzen T-Shirt?
Ja, mit einem Daten-Elch.
Ja, wir haben HDMI.
Wir haben HDMI-Adapter. Jetzt wird hier visuell sozusagen noch beigetragen. Du musst nur sagen.
Ob jugendfrei, alles andere, vertrauen wir dir.
So, dein Applaus für, wie heißt du? Robin. So, dann kriegst du auch ein Headset.
Yeah. So, die Sache läuft. Moin, guten Tag.
Mein erster Kongress und ich sitze in der Freakshow.
Hammer. Du brauchst eigentlich nur einen großen Beamer und dachtest, jetzt nach vorne.
Ja, ich gucke gerade eine Serie.
Dachte ich.
Du hast schon ganz viele Bändchen um den Arm rum. Das sind alles keine Kongressbändchen.
Ja.
Also wäre komisch, wenn es mein erster ist.
Ist es dein erster?
Es ist tatsächlich mein erster, aber das andere ist hier so ein bisschen Hurricane.
Oh, ein Hurricane. Du gehst aufs Hurricane. Also als ich vor zehn Jahren zum
letzten Mal auf dem Hurricane war, da war ich irgendwie 33 und da fragten mich
die um mich rumkämpenden, du gehst aber auch hier hin, um zu sterben, oder?
Das fand ich damals schon hart.
Wird da immer noch hingehen. Aber interessanterweise spielen jetzt immer noch
exakt dieselbe Musik wie vor zehn Jahren.
Wieso ist das so eine Teenager-Veranstaltung? oder was?
Was?
Ist das so eine Teenager-Veranstaltung?
Nee, aber das ist so, Hurricane Festival ist so eines der großen deutschen Festivals,
so eher Indie-Rock mäßig und zwischen Hamburg und Bremen gelegen und das ist
so die klassische Location, wo wenn du in Niedersachsen ein Abi machst,
dann ziehst du danach irgendwie dann aufs Hurricane und begehst das Ganze irgendwie feierlich.
Das ist true. Irgendwie will man ein OBS hier nicht. Probierst du jetzt noch einmal?
Ein bisschen, jetzt wird es voll kompliziert hier.
Bist du ein bisschen rekursiv unterwegs. Ja, aber bevor du vielleicht hier visuell
irgendwas präsentierst, was hast du denn hier so für uns thematisch vorbereitet?
Ja, ich habe gerade überlegt, also mir ist dann aufgefallen,
dass das ja ein Clubhouse ist, in dem Moment, wo ich diesen Raum getreten habe
und dachte so, Scheiße, bereite ich mal was vor, falls dich niemand meldet.
Und dann ist mir eingefallen, was ich vor Weihnachten gemacht habe oder was
mir kurz vor Weihnachten eingefallen ist, leider erst kurz davor.
Und zwar, dass meine Nichte eine Tonybox hat.
Ah, Tonybox, Ralf, dein Thema.
Sie haben mein Interesse geweckt. Reden Sie weiter.
Und dann bin ich neulich oder irgendwie im Laufe des Sommers über diesen letztjährigen
Vortrag von Revox gestoßen. Falls ihr den gesehen habt, hat irgendwer den gesehen.
Die haben nämlich eine Tonybox reverse engineert.
Und dabei sind ja ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, nämlich die Tatsache,
was die Tony Box alles so rapportet.
Also wer nicht weiß, was die Tony Box ist, Tony Box ist dieser,
Reif, beschreib du das mal.
Also Tony Box ist ein, ja, wir haben in der Tat zwei und ich bin da auch Fan
von, wir haben glaube ich 30, 40 Tonys zu Hause.
Also das ist ein Würfel, wirklich ein exakter Würfel.
Kantenlänge ist glaube ich ungefähr so 15x15 cm, vielleicht 20x20,
aber gut handlich für Kinderhände.
Der ist von außen sehr knautschig. Das heißt also, schwer zu beschreiben.
Es ist nicht wirklich wie ein Stofftier, aber halt auch nicht irgendwie was
wie ein harter Gegenstand, sondern sehr angenehm. Man kann so ein bisschen reingreifen.
Und obendrauf ist halt eine Magnetfläche, wo man Figuren draufstellen kann oder andere Objekte.
Meistens sind es aber halt Figuren, die irgendwas mit dem Hörspiel zu tun haben.
Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt ein Asterix-Hörspiel hören möchte,
dann ist es eine Asterix-Figur, wirklich eine 3D-modellierte Asterix-Figur und
da ist ein NFC drin, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht,
der quasi dann das Hörspiel freischaltet und die Hörspiele werden auf den internen
Speicher aus dem Internet geladen.
Das heißt also, wenn man das erste Mal eine Figur kauft, draufstellt,
gibt es einen Download als MP3 meines Wissens, wenn ich nicht richtig im Sinne,
der wird auf einen einigermaßen üppigen internen Speicher gespeichert, so dass es...
Ne, also üppig ist der tatsächlich nicht, das ist eine 8 GB SD-Karte.
MP3-Hörspiele, also kriegst du schon ein paar Hundert, glaube ich, drauf.
Es ist kein MP3, ich komme gerade auch nicht auf das eigentliche Format,
was sie dann kodieren, aber da kommen wir vielleicht gleich nochmal zu, wenn ich das zeige.
Genau, und dann können Kinder das durch die Gegend tragen, ist halt natürlich ein Akku.
Man kann aufladen, die Soundqualität ist okay, reicht auch für ein bisschen Musik hören.
Es gibt Tonys, die man selber bespielen kann, die haben glaube ich 80 Minuten
und es gibt jetzt seit neuestem auch richtig eine neue Konzentration nochmal auf Hörbücher,
wo man dann wirklich ein komplettes Buch eingelesen hat und die sind dann vom
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis ja auch echt ganz cool.
Dann hat man plötzlich ein 4-Stunden-Kinderbuch für irgendwie 12 Euro,
das finde ich dann schon durchaus angemessen.
Dazu muss man jetzt sagen, Ralf hat gerade so eine Zahl von 40 Tonys genannt.
Man muss sich das vorstellen, wenn man bei Ralf in die Küche kommt,
dann hängen alle Tonys am Kühlschrank.
Der sieht aus wie so eine Nietenlederjacke von so einem Punk,
der Kühlschrank ist. Unglaublich.
Früher hatte man so Setzkästen für das, was ein Überraschungsei ist.
Nee, die kleben alle am Küchschrank.
Die sind halt magnetisch. Und im Kinderzimmer, ihr kennt das,
die sind sofort weg und niemand findet mehr irgendwie etwas.
Und wir versuchen unsere Küche umzubauen, so auf Industrieküche.
Ich liebe so diese Edelstahl-Industrieküchen.
Und alle neuen Schränke haben diese Edelstahlfronten und die sind halt magnetisch
genug, dass dann Toni dran pappt.
Und von daher haben wir also unsere komplette Toni-Sammlung,
das stimmt schon, in der Küche hängen.
Großartig. So, und dann saß ich da im Urlaub kurz vor Weihnachten und dachte
so, so ein Toni von Rolf Zukowski mit der Kassette, die meine Schwester und ich damals hatten.
Das war Radio Lollipop, vielleicht irgendwer mal gehört, der ungefähr mein Alter hat.
Nee, wobei deutlich älter ist in deinem Alter. Die ist, glaube ich, von, ich bin 30.
Okay.
Nee, tatsächlich ist die deutlich älter. Die ist von, die ist aus den späten
70ern. Müssen wir vielleicht nochmal gucken.
Radio-Li-Pop uralt, aber war irgendwie die Kassette, die wir gehört haben,
bis sie durchgeleiert ist und nicht mehr funktioniert hat. Und da dachte ich, geil, den Ton nicht.
Gibt's nicht. Selber machen.
Problem, genau. Gibt's nicht, selber machen. und dann diesen Kreativtoni gefunden,
war aber irgendwie nicht so sonderlich überzeugt davon und bin dann über die
Nummer wieder auf diesen Vortrag gekommen.
Dachte, okay, das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht.
Genau, weil der Hintergrund ist, man hat diesen Toni, man stellt ihn da drauf,
und in dem Moment, wo das passiert, reportet diese Tonibox an den Hersteller.
Draufgestellt, wann, so laut gemacht, dabei umgeworfen und das in die Uhrzeit
und dann wieder weg und dann wieder drauf und Und quasi das nutzen sie gerade,
ich habe mir die App ja mal angeguckt, da ist ja auch ein Name im Zweifel des Kindes drin.
Früher haben sie auch noch die WiFi-SSIDs, die umliegenden auch gleich mit supportet.
So entsprechend konnten sie da ein relativ gutes Profile bauen.
Und das hat mir nicht gefallen.
Einfach so aus Prinzip, im Zweifel nennt man das Profile nicht wie das Kind
und dann ist auch alles nicht so wild, aber ich finde das einfach doof.
Dann habe ich angefangen, mir das anzugucken und wie das funktioniert.
Das Problem ist, man muss die Firmware, also man muss einen neuen Bootloader auf die Firmware,
die Box kriegen, muss sie damit zerlegen. Jetzt gibt es Tony Box 1 und Tony Box 2.
Das stimmt aber nicht ganz, es gibt Tony Box 1 bis 4. Quasi die Version 4 ist
die Tony Box 2, dazwischen gibt es noch drei andere, die unter Tony Box 1 gehandelt werden.
So, dann hat meine Schwester geschrieben, so darf ich mir zufälligerweise mal
eure Tony Box ausleihen.
Sie geht auch fast nicht kaputt dabei.
Und sie dann so, nee, tut mir leid, wir sind gerade nicht zu Hause. Ja, okay, dann nicht.
Dann Kleinanzeigen, Tonibox, wunderbar, losgefahren, eine gekauft.
Und es gibt dann jetzt eben die Möglichkeit, einfach, nicht ganz so einfach und fast unmöglich.
Das kannst du aber relativ schwer sehen und wenn du dann da stehst und sagst,
ja, entschuldigen Sie, ich möchte gerne diese Tonibox auf Kleinanzeigen kaufen,
aber darf ich die vorher einmal zerlegen?
Dann funktioniert das nicht. Also habe ich gesagt, komm, Geld hin, aufgemacht.
Und es war jetzt nicht die ganz einfache Variante. Also die Pins sind nicht
rausgelegt, man muss sie sich halt auflöten, weil es auch nicht so wild.
Genau, und dann lötet man das auf und macht einfach einen Programmer dran, einen UART und,
Dann gibt es in dieser von Revox in dieser diesen Wiki, was die haben.
Revox ist jetzt das sind die.
Die quasi diesen Vortrag gemacht haben. Mano.
Wie wir jetzt hier sehen.
Da habe ich mich sogar vertippt, das macht es ganz nicht besser.
Tja, komme ich gleich zu, egal. Die haben das in einem Wiki wunderschön beschrieben,
wie man das machen kann, Und wenn man die, ah, ich kann die Cloud einfach aufmachen,
kann man hier auf Tony-Box hinzufügen klicken.
Schaut, als ob ich nach meiner Lichte geleakt habe. Sorry.
Und kann jetzt sagen, was habe ich denn hier für einen Tony.
Und ich hatte eben den Tony in der Variante. Da drückt man dann drauf.
CC3200.
Genau. Das ist eben der Texas Instrument Chips, den sie in der Version 1 da
drauf gelötet haben. später, es ist ein ESP32 geworden, da haben sie praktischerweise
das Programming Interface einfach gar nicht von dem PCB runtergenommen,
da kommt man direkt drauf.
Hier muss man sich das halt wieder mit ein paar Kälbchen anlöten,
hier wird es dann beschrieben und geht das dann durch, flasht dann eben,
also zieht sich erstmal die, die,
Und die Zertifikate, die offiziellen von Tony runter, damit man die hat,
die werden dann in die Oberfläche hier reingefüttert, sodass quasi diese Oberfläche,
die ich jetzt hier baue, die läuft bei mir lokal einfach auf dem Proxmox vor sich hin,
quasi der offizielle Verbindung zu Tonys Cloud aufbaut und eine Zwischenstelle
ergibt zwischen der Tonybox und eben der offiziellen Tony-Seite.
Das heißt, wir können entscheiden, was senden wir Tonys und was nicht.
Ich habe es jetzt so eingestellt, ich kriege aber nur Daten von denen.
Wenn ich einen Tony da drauf stelle, kriege ich die Daten, alles andere kriegen
die von mir nicht mehr. Das ist halt ganz schön.
Wie das weiter funktioniert, dafür haben die das gemacht, kann man sich wunderbar
angucken. und wenn das dann läuft, kann man eben was ganz Schönes machen,
wenn diese Tony-Box da jetzt drin ist und man die hinzugefügt hat.
Wenn das dann geklappt hat, ich habe so zwei, drei Anläufe gebraucht,
bis das dann lief, dann kann man eben hier auf den Audio-Encoder gehen. Das sind TF-Daten.
Also mit hier meinst du jetzt genau, welche Webseite?
Das ist jetzt, deswegen habe ich extra OBS gecroppt genommen.
Wir müssen das ja auch für die zukünftigen Hörer alles noch.
Stimmt. Also ich habe es jetzt extra gecroppt, damit man die DNS nicht sieht,
die ich dafür genommen habe.
Genau, das ist eben der Server, der bei mir zu Hause lokal läuft.
Aha, Privatkram.
Privatkram, genau, den habe ich dadurch, dass er bei mir läuft,
meiner Schwester aber von überall darauf zugreifen will, habe ich den eben public gemacht.
Das kann man natürlich auch als lokal laufen lassen. Revox,
tendenziell auch empfohlen, das lokal bei sich zu machen. Ich habe es jetzt
eben so rumgebaut, das heißt, das Ding braucht nur WLAN und dann spielt das irgendwie los.
So, und dann schmeißt man jetzt die Audio-Dateien in welcher Form auch immer
da rein und die werden in diese THF-Daten konvertiert und dann kann man sich
hier so einen Tony nehmen, das ist jetzt irgendein Tony-Tag und das ist das Wichtige.
Man kann sich irgendeinen RFID-Tag nehmen, den schmeißt man einmal da drauf
und dann taucht er hier als Fragezeichen auf.
Das heißt, man braucht keinen originalen Tony mehr dafür.
Und dann linkt man einfach die Audio-Datei da rein, wenn man das da drauf legt, spielt das los.
TAF ist jetzt welches File genau, also ist das das Audio-File?
Das ist das Audio-File, genau. Deswegen haben sie extra einen Encoder gleich mit reingebaut.
Das ist das Tony Audio-File sozusagen, ja.
Ist das Proprietär?
Inwiefern?
Naja, das Audio-Format, ist das Proprietär?
Ja, ist es. Es gibt hier Converter.
Tav gibt es für...
Ja, aber Tav kommt ja auch woanders vor, meines Wissens nach.
Also das ist jetzt nichts, was sie extra erfunden haben.
Ja, aber ich habe davon nie gehört irgendwie.
Nicht so wichtig.
Ja, genau. Und weil da eben noch keiner von gehört hat, haben sie gleich den
Encoder mit reingebaut, was ganz schön ist.
Also reinschmeißen, die encodieren das für dich quasi auf der Plattform,
die man da baut, Pock das da rein und schön.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, was ein schöner Nebeneffekt ist,
weil darauf hatte ich ja gar keinen Fokus, in dem Moment, wo dann der Toni,
der Original-Toni auf dem der gehackten Toni-Box steht,
hat man die THF-Dateien des Original-Tonis auch zur freien Verfügung in seiner Cloud.
Das ist ganz schön, weil jetzt kann man so schöne Toni-Box-Partys machen.
Und dann eben gleich gespielt.
Ich zeig dir da eins.
Und kann dann eben einfach wieder normale, also selbstgemachte Chips nehmen,
RFID-Chips und die drauflegen und die quasi an die Originaldatei binden und
schon hat man da eine Kopie hergestellt.
Theoretisch, wenn man jetzt diese kriminelle Energie hätte, das zu tun.
Genau. Und das ist wirklich einfach sehr praktisch und alle,
die irgendwie genau, nicht wie auch immer haben.
Das ist das mega Geschenk. Also meine Schwester hat sich auf den Kopf gestellt.
Ja, dann eine Figur 3D-Drucken, die dann noch dazu passt und dann ist man der totale Winner.
Genau, also das hatte ich dann quasi.
Genau, das habe ich dann auf meinem 3D-Drucker angefangen und erstmal quasi
für das Level 1, das ist jetzt einfach nur ein Chip, der in zwei Teile gedruckt wird.
quasi eine Oberseite und eine Unterseite und in die Oberseite klebt man eben
den RFID-Aufkleber rein, macht es zu, dann hat man schon mal eine schöne Basis,
das funktioniert auch so.
Das Wichtige ist auch, dass man diesen Abstand hat. Also man sieht hier eben,
dass die untere Platte so ein paar Millimeter höher ist und dann erst der Tag
reingeklebt wird, weil sonst liest die Box das tatsächlich nicht.
Weil der RFID-Laser irgendwie so außen rum ist und der braucht so einen gewissen
Abstand, damit das geht.
Und dann hat man tatsächlich ein Basement, wo man dann, wir waren jetzt zuletzt
bei Fimo Figuren oder man kauft irgendwas oder man druckt eben was aus das war
jetzt halt, wie gesagt ich hatte die Idee irgendwie am 20. 21.
Dezember war das dann nicht mehr drin mit noch Figuren drucken mit verschiedenen
Farben und überhaupt deswegen waren es erstmal nur die Chips und wir kleben
dann da Schleichfiguren oder so Schlümpfe.
Weil du hast jetzt kein Rolf Zukowski ausgedruckt und selbst bemalt.
Ich habe ein Radio ausgedruckt für besagtes Album, aber ich fand das dann hässlich,
deswegen habe ich dann einfach nur quasi Radio Lollipop draufgeschrieben, dann mit 3T-Druck.
So, und dann funktionierte das auch und alle waren total.
Also, warme Empfehlung, Megaprojekt, nochmal Props an die.
Du hast es, glaube ich, deshalb nicht gefunden, weil sich Revox mit Doppel-V schreibt.
Tony-Wiki.revox.de und dann Teddy Cloud.
Genau, also da nochmal. Du treibst ja da in den Einsatz.
Oder? Also, ich meine, du bist ja jetzt bestimmt schon auf Touren, oder?
Ja, also der Vollständigkeit halber, ich meine, der Kongress ist wahrscheinlich
irgendwie der falsche Ort, um es vielleicht aber auch doch wieder der richtige Ort.
Ja, das kannst du schon alles machen,
aber es gibt halt auch 13.000 Open-Source-Alternativen zur Tonybox.
Ja, natürlich.
Also eigene Hardware bauen, die auf Raspberry Pi basieren viele von denen auf
und mit Rezepten für einen 3D-Drucker, also auch irgendwie ein cooles Case dafür
bauen kannst und so und die dann halt genau mit einer ähnlichen freien NFC-Infrastruktur dann laufen.
Da würde ich dann fast überlegen, ob das dann nicht eigentlich der coolere und
konsequentere Weg ist, dass dann wirklich so gleich richtig Open Source zu machen,
aber das ist jetzt noch ein bisschen because we can, aber okay.
Und es war so eine EDA-Nummer, also gut, dass ich das Ding jetzt bei kleiner
Zeit gekauft habe, extra dafür war jetzt nicht im Planen begriffen,
aber die waren nun mal nicht da und ich wollte es halt unbedingt,
jetzt haben sie halt dann zwei gehackte Boxen.
Das ist ja auch okay.
Hast du ja gesagt, eine ist besser, also ich lese mal ein paar Phonybox.
Ton, Unibox, Multipiebox, Weezybox, smarter Music Machine, also der Alternativen
sind da viele, aber trotzdem cool.
Verstehe. Das Audioformat ist übrigens Opus und in einem Ock-Container mit einem
Custom-Header und das ist dann halt dieses Tough. Also okay, es ist nicht.
Das war ja fast zu erwarten.
Ja, cool.
Sehr gerne.
Ich mache eigentlich Veranstaltungstechnik.
Früher mal Audio, dann bin ich so Videot geworden über Corona,
so wie viele andere auch, weil es musste halt gemacht werden.
Dann habe ich irgendwie drei Jahre meines Lebens Sendungen geschnitten,
also live geschnitten, habe da auch sehr großen Gefallen dran gefunden.
Man landet so ein Delirium, man setzt so das Ding auf und dann hat man die Hände
auf dem Tisch und dann hat man so vier, fünf Kameraleute und dann sagt man eben,
Achtung, eins, eins. Achtung, vier, vier.
Achtung, sagt man da?
Also man sagt dann, man warnt eben die Kameraperson vor, dass sie gleich dran ist.
Das heißt, du holst sie dann in den Preview, du hattest schon mal gesehen,
eine grüne und rote Lampe, die dann auf den Kameras drauf ist.
Grün ist immer, dass du vorgewählt bist. Das heißt, du könntest gleich rankommen.
Da kann man auch lustige Spiele mitspielen. Man kann immer gucken,
wenn Leute am Einpennen sind, an der Kamera macht man die mal grün.
Dann sind die auch wieder wach.
Und dann macht man das aber nochmal, weil die Kameraleute oder Kamera- und Bimi-Bildmischer
dann in einem Kreis immer abgeschlossen sind.
Quatscht man eh die ganze Zeit. Das ist auch das Schöne daran,
weil alle anderen halten die Klappe. Gerade als Ton. Das ist total doof,
weil du musst da zuhören, kannst ja nicht reden nebenbei.
Und irgendwie im Videochat ist man quasi die ganze Zeit nur am babbeln und irgendwie
dumme Witze machen. Und dem mal sagt man eben, Achtung, eins, eins.
Und dann weiß er, dass da drauf ist. Und dann kommt man so durch so einen Tag, egal wie,
langweilig der Vortrag ist, den man im Zweifel dazuhören muss,
man ist irgendwie beschäftigt.
Macht ihr noch spitze Kommentare über den Vortrag?
Nein, nein, nein. Also da irgendeinen abfälligen Kommentar finden darüber.
Oder wenn irgendeine Person aus der Politik kommt, die man vielleicht nicht mag.
Verstehe, da hält man sich zurück. So soll es sein.
Vor allem, weil theoretisch nicht Appelsicherheit deckt. Also da könnte problematisch sein.
Aber bis jetzt bin ich noch nicht auf die Füße gefallen.
Super, toller Beitrag, Robin. Danke, dass ich da sein durfte. Danke.
Ja, ja, Veranstaltungstechnik. Events haben irgendwie immer was,
weiß ich nicht, da knistert es immer. Ich verstehe das schon.
So.
Ich trinke langsam Bier, merke ich.
Trinkst Bier langsam oder trinkst langsam Bier?
Ich komme aus einer Familie, da muss man schnell essen und schnell trinken, sonst war alles weg.
Achso, du meinst, du trinkst ein Bier langsam.
Also ich habe jetzt so viel getrunken, wie er noch in der Flasche hat.
Fast gar nichts sozusagen.
Ja, das ist Kompensation.
Aber gut.
Ja. So, Leute, ihr wisst, die Sendung ist gleich vorbei. Es sei denn, ihr macht mit.
Ich sehe eine Hand, die sich meldet. und ich bitte auf die Bühne. Udo.
Da wusste ich jetzt schon vorher Bescheid.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe was mitgebracht.
Geschenke, endlich.
Es gibt Neuigkeiten im Projekt Ultraschall. Die erste Abfüllung.
Ach, mehr zu trinken.
Ultraschall, Soundbord.
In Gelb.
Hier weiterreichen.
Und ich dachte vielleicht als kurze Erfrischung, dann habt ihr was.
Was ist das? Achso, ist das.
Ein Mango-Vanille-Getränk mit 16 Volumenprozent.
Ist das das, was man beim Inder immer bekommt, bevor man geht?
Nö, aus dem Supermarkt.
Das war bestimmt lecker. Okay, du musst mal ein bisschen erläutern.
Also Ultraschall, wir reden natürlich hier von eurem Projekt.
Von diesem Ultraschall, was Ton macht, nicht was Bilder macht.
Was ihr jetzt wahrscheinlich auch aufnimmt, oder? Ja.
Ich hoffe auch Multitrack, ja.
Grüß dich hin.
Ja, okay. Mit Kapitelmarken, macht ihr auch Kapitelmarken? Nein?
Was musst du da machen?
Und Udo ist ja auch seit langer Zeit Teil dieses Projekts. Das ist noch nie
in der Freakshow, glaube ich, oder?
Das ist auffallend richtig.
Das ist ein Skandal. Okay, dann haben wir das ja. Okay, aber gibt es jetzt nur
um Alkohol oder hast du noch einen anderen Beitrag?
Ich könnte was erzählen zu dem Ultraschallgerät.
Was hier ja vor Ort steht.
Könnt ihr mir jemand diese Postkarten, die da vorne liegen? Nee,
hier auf der Lautsprecherbox. Die wollte ich eigentlich mitbringen.
Ich halte es mal in die Kamera und ihr habt es vielleicht gesehen,
da hinten im Sendezentrum steht so ein 18 Jahre altes Ultraschall.
So ein Schwangerschaftsdetektor.
Nee, es ist für Herz gedönsgedacht.
Also ich glaube, ich muss mal kurz Meta sagen. Habe ich eigentlich hier irgendwie
so einen fetten Kompressor drauf, weil ich irgendwie mich selber...
Klinge ich leise?
Leiser als sonst, aber das ist ganz angenehm.
Vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Gain irgendwie.
Ich glaube, das geht uns aber allen so. Wir hören uns selber alle nicht so laut.
Ja.
Du kannst hier noch nachlesen.
Dann höre ich euch lauter.
Euch höre ich ja laut, aber ich höre mich nicht laut.
Jetzt siehst du mal, wie das ist.
Kannst du mich einen Hauch lauter machen? Bist du mich rot?
Du bist blau. Was bin ich? Ja, wissen Sie nicht, bei was bin ich?
Du bist, glaube ich, lila. Ach nee, du bist blau.
Test, test, test. Ja, so ist gut. Danke.
Okay, wir nehmen es jetzt, wie es ist.
Genau, also ich habe dieses Jahr wieder dieses Ultraschallgerät mitgemacht in
Version 2.0. Letztes Mal war es Version 1, da hatte ich es 14 Tage.
Das ist wirklich ein Gerät, das ist eigentlich nur eine Hülle.
Es ist das größte Computergehäuse, was ich je besessen habe.
Ja.
Mit eingebautem Monitor. Es hat ein paar neue Features, wie ein Katzen-Aufkleberspender.
Ein Katzen-Aufkleberspender. Okay.
Vorne eingebaut, kann man rausziehen. Dann hat es eine neue Tastatur,
die ich selber gebaut habe, so eine mechanische, die genau in dieses merkwürdige Format reinpasst.
Es hat jetzt ein Audio-Interface 4 Spur bekommen. Letztes Mal waren es nur 2.
Was ist noch neu? Ah, es hat ein Audio-Steckfeld gekriegt, so ein richtig gutes
Broadcast-Lemo-Steckfeld, für die wissen, was das ist.
Und XNR-Buchsen, damit man die Mikros reinstecken kann.
Ultraschall kann jetzt Karaoke.
Ralf, ich bin überrascht.
Ich versuche gerade irgendwo ein aktuelles Bild zu finden.
Was heißt denn das?
Du hast noch nichts gepostet.
Machst du gerne, gehst du gerne?
Nein, nein, aber es war letztes Jahr so, dass ich da stand und die erste Interaktion,
ich gerät plus fremde Personen, war eine junge Asiatin,
ungelogen, die ganz aufgeregt auf mich zulief und auf Englisch fragte,
sorry, sorry, ist das der Karaoke-Machine?
Und dann musste ich sagen, sorry, no, jetzt habe ich ihr das erklärt,
deutsche Sound, bla bla bla, Wortspiel, ich musste es kaufen.
Und dann ging sie ziemlich, also so gelangweilt, ein bisschen beleidigt weg.
Und dann dachte ich.
Gleich vom Start erstmal eine Frau enttäuscht. Es läuft einfach richtig hier.
Genau, so kann das nicht weitergehen. Und dann gab es auch so einen gelben Aktenordner,
wo Leute Wünsche reinschreiben konnten.
Da hatten dann auch zwei oder drei Personen reingeschrieben,
Karaoke. Und dann habe ich mal geguckt.
Ja, da sieht man das Gerät.
Ich habe es mal auf dem Beamer.
Wie man hier sieht.
Das ist aber die Version vom letzten Jahr.
Also wenn ihr schon mal ein Kind bekommen habt, dann wisst ihr, was gemeint ist.
Da sieht man noch die schreckliche Tastatur.
Ach, dafür wird das auch verwendet? Ja.
So in den Bauch gucken.
Ohne aufschneiden. So ein voluminöses Computer-Terminal, in dem Fall von General
Electric, was so ein bisschen aussieht, als ob es von diesem furchtbaren Designer,
wie hieß der noch gleich, dieser furchtbare...
Ich weiß, Colani.
Colani.
Unter anderem auch das. Egal, wir reden wir nicht über ihn, aber das ist auf
jeden Fall ein gewagtes Design.
Schon mal ein Spoiler für die nächste Freakshow. Man sieht hier Buttons,
die vermutlich gute Druckpunkte haben.
Dieses Ding wird sich bedienen lassen mit Buttons.
Was heißt, wird sich vielleicht bedienen lassen?
Wird sich gut bedienen lassen.
Was heißt, wird sich? Es lässt sich noch nicht gut bedienen lassen.
Könnt ihr ja nachher ausprobieren. Die Tastatur hat jetzt schöne Tasten,
also es sind richtige Mechanical Keyboard MX-Tasten, die man auch tauschen kann.
Also ich habe ein komplett neues Keyboard. Das Keyboard, was ihr da nicht seht,
ist das vom letzten Jahr.
Da sieht man ja auch diese graue Space-Taste und so. Das war alles ein bisschen...
Die Tasten haben geklemmt. Das war nicht schön.
Die ist neu, wird aber vielleicht auch noch eine neue Version kommen mit schöneren
Tasten und mit schöneren Keycaps. Mal gucken. Ähm...
Genau, und mein Projekt ist jedes Jahr dieses Ding mitbringen und jedes Mal
etwas neuer und besser machen. Ja, aber jetzt Karaoke.
Achso, ja, Karaoke.
Also es gibt, ich hole aus, es gibt ein Spiel, das kennt ihr alle von der alten Playstation 2 oder 1,
Singstar.
Sorry, ich nix, Gaming.
Wer kennt Singstar?
Ja, Gott, alle.
Über die Hälfte, fast alle. Singstar was a thing, das ist ein Spiel,
da kriegst du einen Song, du
musst mitsingen und wenn du die Noten richtig triffst, kriegst du Punkte.
Ah.
Also das zeigt dann so an, so eine Kurve.
Naja. Wie genau muss man die Noten treffen?
Keine Ahnung. Halbton wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß es nicht. Genau.
Kannst auch mitzoomen, es geht nur um die Frequenz.
Exakt. Also es spielt deine persönliche Glücksmelodie und dann...
Genau, und wenn du richtig mitzoomst, hast du gewonnen. Dieses Spiel...
Bitte geben dir eine Münche ein.
...wurde dann open-gesourced. also Leute haben eine Open-Source-Variante davon
gebaut und jetzt haltet euch fest, wie das hieß, Ultrastar.
Das ist noch weit vor Ultrastar. Aber es gibt das Spiel Ultrastar für Windows
und ich glaube auch für Linux und es ist schrecklich, es ist irgendwie aus den wahrscheinlich 90ern.
Ich glaube, es ist in Pascal programmiert oder wie heißt das?
Delphi, in Delphi glaube ich.
Es gibt Ultrastar Deluxe.
Ja, das ist der Nachfolger, der kann auch sein, dass der Geile Webseite.
Steht eigentlich nur aus 25 verschiedenen Releases.
Ich meine, viele andere Projekte haben nur...
6. Dezember 25, was will man mehr?
Ja, siehst du mal.
Guck mal, sieht man da nicht, was alles ist.
Irgendwas mit Windows.
Aber irgendwie so ein Screenshot wäre auch schon geil, oder?
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall, dieses Spiel gibt es. Und es gibt natürlich wie immer bei sowas,
es gibt eine unfassbar große Community, die dann diese Songs da reinhacken.
Also du musst ja den Song in Noten aufteilen und den Text eingeben und das quasi taken.
Und dann gibt es so Textdateien im Ultra-Star-Format.
Und ich habe dann geguckt und das ist einfach eine Textdatei,
Da steht dann sowas drin wie Timecode, Note, O, also O und H,
weil das O gesungen wird und dann nächste Zeile, nächste Note,
nächstes Wort und so weiter.
Da dachte ich schon, hm, vielleicht kann man das irgendwie in Parser bauen,
in Lua und dann importiert man das, stellt sich raus, hat schon einer gemacht.
Ein Importer für Reaper.
Ein Importer für Reaper, um diese Dateien zu importieren, bearbeiten, wieder zu exportieren.
Also man kann Reaper als Editor benutzen, um diese Dinger zu bauen.
Und dann habe ich einfach mal so 10, 20 Songs vorbereitet, habe mir noch mit
so einem KI-Programm die Musik getrennt in Sprache und Rest.
Das heißt, du kannst die Originalgesangen, die Lautstärke regeln,
je nachdem, wie textsicher und einsatzsicher du bist.
und man könnte jetzt theoretisch da mit Karaoke machen. Also mit Reaper schrägstrich. Wie theoretisch?
Das sollten wir doch nach der Sendung.
Ja, das geht.
Wir können das testen. Ein Song ist richtig gut vorbereitet,
den Rest ist gefrickelt, aber theoretisch können wir heute Abend Uptown Girl
für die Kühlschrankbesitzer könnten mal singen. Das ist vorbereitet.
Ich habe vorhin auch schon Leute gemacht. Kinder haben auch viel Spaß gehabt
beim Schreinen in dieses Mikro.
Also du sagst jetzt nach der Sendung nicht weggehen, sondern vorne am Ultraschalltreffen.
Wer sich das antun möchte, können wir das gerne machen. Also das ist die,
nee, wir wollten eigentlich arbeiten.
Wenn die Sterne günstig stehen, kriegen wir heute noch eine Release fertig.
Auf den Kongress.
Vergiss es, ist lebendig.
Das haben wir auch schon mal geschafft. Es hängt gerade noch an der Retinarisierung der Linux-Version.
Das ist leider Cupsoftus-Fledermaus-Land.
Ja, Linux ist kompliziert. Also nein, Linux ist nicht kompliziert,
aber Reaper auf Linux ist kompliziert.
Hält uns alle auf.
Aber dieses Gesöffel ist sehr lecker hier. Ich finde das gut. Mehr davon.
Es kommt nur fast nichts raus.
Es kommt von dem deutschen Hersteller mit B und davon dann Mango-Vanille für die, die es nachkommt.
Oh, der aus Niedersachsen, der mit dem B?
Ja.
Oh Gott, da war ich mal.
Der mit dem Spaß im Glas.
Da wird mal abgefüllt.
Ich glaube, die auch Apfelkorn und so haben. Es war halt gelb.
Ja, ist auch sehr gelb.
Ich habe auch noch ein paar schwarze oder dunkle.
Genau, das war's. Ich wollte eigentlich nur für eine Erfrischung ein bisschen Dank machen.
Ist dir gelungen.
Danke. Das war's. Wer noch Postkarten möchte, gibt es vorne ein Unterstellgerät.
So, läuft doch super hier. Jetzt die bange Frage.
Wird es noch eine Hand geben?
Natürlich wird es eine Hand geben, weil sonst ist die Sendung ja vorbei.
Das kann niemand wollen.
Das kann niemand wollen und deswegen Deswegen wird sich jetzt auch eine Hand
heben. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Könnt ihr mit Karaoke was anfangen?
Also, wie viele Stunden hast du Zeit? In einem meiner früheren Leben war ich
mal wirklich ganz tief im Ribbit Hole von Plastic Rock.
Oh, ich glaube, das Thema hatten wir schon mal. Das hatte ich aber schon mal kurz angedacht.
Also nicht nur singen, sondern auch noch Plastikschlagzeug, Plastikgitarren, Plastikbarz und so.
Und eine der Dinge, wo ich wirklich denke, die Welt ist schlechter geworden,
ist, dass es das nicht mehr gibt. Ich fand das so fantastisch auf so vielen Ebenen.
Plastikrock.de hatte ich damals
mit Claudia die größte deutschsprachige Community aufgebaut da drum.
Und wir hatten ein Live-Treffen und es war einfach eine sehr viel schönere Welt.
Und Karaoke ist nur so die kleine, traurige Schwester davon.
Also wenn du so nach Japan fährst und da auch vielleicht mit Japanern was zu
tun hast, ich bin dem gerade so entkommen, dann ist das ja geradezu,
also da musst du ja das ja machen.
Wurde mir berichtet. Also ich musste es Gott sei Dank nicht machen,
aber man läuft schnell in die Situation, weil das dann einfach so eine selbstverständliche
Tätigkeit ist, die dann sozusagen so komplett. und ich, ehrlich gesagt,
ich habe Schwierigkeiten, das so nachzufühlen.
Also ich kann diese Karaoke-Begeisterung, das weiß ich nicht,
das ist bei mir wie Gaming, das heilt einfach nicht in mir.
Ich habe ja auch mal in einer Band gesungen, also hauptsächlich schlaft es euch
gespielt, aber auch ein bisschen gesungen, das ist immer sehr gefährlich, wenn der Drummer singt,
aber grundsätzlich finde ich das fantastisch, Karaoke, aber wenn dann der eigene
Anspruch wieder zu hoch ist, Und oh nein, ich singe nur diese drei Lieder,
weil die kann ich richtig gut.
Dann ist das Game-Prinzip halt auch schon wieder kaputt. Also von daher hoffe
ich auch noch auf irgendwelche Karaoke-Veranstaltungen, wo man mal den Geist
ganz locker und frei macht und einfach Spaß hat.
Ja, man muss sich schon zum Affen machen wollen, sonst ist Karaoke nicht das Richtige.
Das ist eben nicht meine Stärke, also zumindest nicht in dem Kontext.
Sicher.
In dem Kontext.
Ah, okay.
Ja, ja, das ist schwierig. Drama, ja, warte mal, Drama, da fällt mir doch gerade was ein.
Es gibt Videos von mir, aber die sind nicht Google-indexiert, von daher vergiss es.
Ja, an der Stelle eine kurze Empfehlung, das fällt mir jetzt gerade so ein, weil ich das gerade...
Willst du die OL rüber schmeißen?
Dann kann ich auch... Ich kann das hier einfach abspielen.
Die Leute sehen dann nichts, sondern sie hören es nur. Das ist dem Wunsch.
Das ist halt ein Audio-Podcast. So weird.
Ralf hat noch Schwierigkeiten.
Du kannst das schnell nachschlagen. Star Power Drummer.
Ein Schlagzeuger, der so auf YouTube seine Clips veröffentlicht.
Und der die besondere Eigenschaft hat, Breakbeats zu spielen.
Also mit dem Schlagzeug, normalerweise hast du ja immer relativ gleichmäßige
Geschichten, aber bei ihm läuft das halt irgendwie anders.
Irre, oder?
Der Fairness halber muss man jetzt sagen, es war ein Cover. Und der Original-Drummer
spielt es ja auch irgendwie, oder?
Nee, er spielt von, vielleicht habe ich jetzt gerade das falsche Beispiel rausgesucht,
aber er spielt halt Tracks, die so Breakbeats sind, wo das aber alles normalerweise
komponierter Techno ist.
Also er spielt dir den Armenbrake mal so eben aus dem Handgelenk und das ist einfach crazy.
Ich habe so ein längeres Video gesehen, wo er irgendwie so seine ganze Technik
erklärt und das ist wieder so, wo man so davor sitzt und sich so denkt, so,
Alright, awesome, man. Also er hat wirklich Fähigkeiten.
Ja, also für euch zur Erklärung, das war jetzt gerade nicht in Sync.
Ich hatte jetzt ein x-beliebiges Video von ihm hier gerade abgespielt,
von daher das war jetzt vielleicht etwas verwirrend von Textbildschere.
Ja, ja.
Aber ja, also Drummer-Videos auf YouTube sind in der Tat ein schönes Ribbit-Hole.
Also was ich mal am schrillsten finde, ist sehr komplizierte Drumtracks und
dann echte Profi-Drummer, die es live zum ersten Mal hören und so fort.
Perfekt nachspielen können.
Das ist also aus einem Level, wo ich dann also irgendwie zwei Stunden mir einen
abfrummel, so wie die hören das einmal und schauen das einfach raus und das
menschliche Gehirn ist schon wild, was sowas angeht.
Es ist wild, das ist wahr.
Die nächste Hand.
Genau, jetzt einer von euch muss dran glauben, irgendwelche interessanten Schwenke
aus eurem Leben. Ihr habt die Wahl, ja.
Wir wollen jetzt hier oder ihr könnt natürlich alternativ, ihr könnt uns auch Dinge fragen.
Das haben wir ja auch gesagt. Ja, ihr könnt auch die Moderation übernehmen.
Man muss ja nicht unbedingt immer wieder was.
Es gibt eine Hand.
Ja, na bitteschön, der Robert, hallo. Komm mal ran.
Wo ist Werner? Er trägt ein T-Shirt.
Hooray.
So, Hallöchen.
Hallo.
Hallöchen. Nochmal das Mikrofon richten.
So.
Auf geht's.
Also ich könnte auch über Drumvideos reden.
Kannst du. Okay.
Gezwungenermaßen, das war eigentlich, worüber ich reden wollte.
Ja, okay, gut. Wie du möchtest.
Ich habe eine Frage an euch.
Okay, dann mal los.
Also ich mache ja in einer südlichen Landeshauptstadt des Landes hier den Presseonkel
für den lokalen CCC-Branch.
Ja.
Und da ist relativ wenig Presse eher so, können Sie nicht auf unser Panel kommen
und was über Digitalisierung sagen?
Geil.
Das sind die Besten.
Ja.
Aber jetzt habe ich im Januar einen Termin, der ist besser. Also der ist ernsthaft gut.
Und da soll ich vor jungen Leuten...
mich auslassen über früher, damals im Internet. Ich frage das euch als alte, weiße Männer.
Ich habe es mir gedacht. Das sind wir, die Spezialexperten hier.
Nein, nein, Huckel ist ja nicht da. Damals, als wir irgendwie NNTP entdeckt
haben und es die Gruppen mit mindestens drei oder vier oder fünf Punkten,
die jedes Spezialgebiet behandelt haben.
Ja, er redet von Newsnet, Newsgroups.
Jeder King findet den Longtail im Internet und alles wird gut und wir werden alle demokratisch.
Und irgendwas ist zwischendurch passiert. Und jetzt haben wir nur noch Nazis
und Verschwörungstheoretiker.
Wo sind wir falsch abgebogen?
Das sollen wir jetzt beantworten.
Ich muss das dann da zwei Stunden lang beantworten. Und jetzt könnt ihr mal
eure zwei Minuten sehen.
Vielleicht sind wir auch nur falsch gerade ausgefahren. Und hätten abbieten sollen.
Also ich hätte so einen Messpunkt, den ich da reinbringen würde,
weil das glaube ich was ist, womit die Jugend noch was anfangen kann.
Und das hatte Mark-Uwe Kling gestern Abend auch in seinem Talk,
nämlich dieses Link in der Bio.
Wer weiß, welcher Dienst zum allerersten Mal Link in der Bio,
drin hatte.
Zum allerersten Mal, ja, Insta oder nicht?
Genau. Instagram zwei Jahre nach Launch, wo sie ihren ersten großen Sale hatten,
das heißt, wo sie zum ersten Mal aufgekauft worden sind und,
dann gab es halt diese Policy so, egal was die Leute irgendwie auf Insta posten,
wenn da ein Link drin ist, wird er rausgefiltert und ist kaputt und damit die
Leute überhaupt noch irgendwie auf ihre eigenen Dienste was verlinken konnten,
hieß es dann halt immer so, Link findet ihr in der Bio,
also sprich in der Beschreibung des Accounts, weil da waren die Links noch die
Outgoing-Links noch erlaubt.
Eine meiner Thesen, und ich glaube, wie gesagt, Marc Uhr hatte den Punkt gestern
auch gemacht, ist, dass das eine der Ursünden des klassischen Internets waren.
Zu sagen so, diese Fähigkeit, das Internet ist ein verlinkter Ort,
wo alle Informationen von A nach B fließen kann und alle Brücken gut und stabil
funktionieren und es ist egal,
wo über welche Brücke du gehst, es ist immer cool, Hauptsache du bist irgendwie im Internet.
Dieser Gesellschaftsvertrag, der wurde aufgekündigt, einseitig von Instagram.
Und das wäre für mich so einer der Punkte, wo ich sagen würde,
da ist massiv zum ersten Mal falsch abgewogen worden.
Also ich stimme dir zu, aber ich glaube, die Anrichtung war ja auch schon vorher kaputt.
Also dieses ewige Jetzt, was einmal oben raus oder unten rausgescrollt ist,
ist nicht mehr wieder auffindbar von diesem ganzen Social-Media-Ding.
Also in Facebook rein verlinken kann man auch nicht gescheit.
Und alte Twitter-Posts kann man irgendwie verlinken, aber wer,
wie wir das alle gemacht haben, unseren Twitter-Account gekündigt hat,
wir können auch nicht mal in Twitter reingucken, weil da immer steht,
sie müssen sich aber einloggen, ihr Account ist gelöscht, sie wollten nicht mehr mit uns spielen.
Und ich bin gespannt, wann ihr eure Apple-ID abschafft.
Ja, in der Tat. Ich habe am Anfang mit diesem Digital Independence Day.
Man baut sofort im Kopf so ein Ranking.
Ja, okay, das tut mir echt nicht weh. Insta, da habe ich seit Jahren nichts
mehr. So, klar, nächste Woche, ganz demonstrativ werde ich da zu Pixel fette.
Aber so nach unten, so in die unteren Layer, da wird es dann schon ganz schön
schmerzhaft. Schmerzhaft.
Es ist nicht falsch, wenn du sagst, die Apple-ID, die wird schon wehtun, die loszuwerden.
Übrigens mit der neuen Apple-Podcast-App. Die Apple-Podcast-App,
die zeigt dir auch alle Links, die du in deinen Kapitelmarken drin hast, an.
Also alle, solange sie auf Apple-Produkte zeigen.
Oh Gott, das habe ich gehört. Ja, das ist meine Güte.
Da muss auch irgendwie dringend mal jemand zurücktreten bei euch.
Also es wird echt höchste Zeit.
Es ist alles Security.
Aber ich meine, diese ganze Wahrnehmung, dass damals ja alles schon richtig gut gewesen wäre.
Nein, aber das ist eine gute Zukunft vor uns stand, haben wir.
Ja, also wir haben das zumindest eine Weile geglaubt, sagen wir es mal so.
Und es ging auch voran. Ich weiß noch, als wir von Ski Physics haben wir eine
Abstimmung gemacht und Ski Physics Research gegründet 1994.
Und das war die moderierte Physikgruppe. Da waren dann die ganzen Einstein-Leugner
raus und da konnten sich Leute… Die es.
Gab sozusagen damals schon.
Ja, die gab es schon immer, also seit 1905.
Ja, das hat Tradition, meinst du? Ja, kennst du noch den Begriff Imminent Death of the Net Predicted?
Habt ihr das mal gehört? Nein, ist eine stehende Terminologie aus den frühen
90er Jahren oder Ende der 80er Jahre,
als sozusagen das Usenet, nee 90er Jahre genau, als so AOL Internetzugang angeboten hat.
America Online, die mit den CDs und so. Als die verbunden wurden.
Genau, die haben dann sozusagen quasi so die Tür aufgemacht so zum Usenet.
Und dann gab es halt so eine Phase, wo sozusagen an jedem Tag des Jahres mehr
User neu waren, als es irgendwie bisher User insgesamt gab und so.
Und alles brach dann halt über diese Usenet-Foren einher und alles waren nur
noch irgendwelche Neulinge.
Das hatte doch so einen Monat, ne? Dark Oktober oder sowas? Irgendwie sowas war das?
Das….
Der ewige September.
Der ewige September, den Begriff habe ich gerade gar nicht parat.
Doch, ich google das mal.
Naja, auf jeden Fall gab es dann aber auch so diese Aussage,
dass jetzt bald alles vorbei ist.
Also imminent death of the net predicted war dann sozusagen so der Running Gag,
was ja dann aber trotzdem irgendwie nicht stattgefunden hat.
Trotz alledem hat sich ja dann auch sehr schnell angezeigt.
in dem Moment, wo du genug Leute in einer Gruppe zusammen hast,
so ab einer bestimmten Zahl, bricht halt irgendwie jede Zivilisation auch schnell
zusammen und dann wird dann einfach nur noch gehatet und getrollt und was nicht alles.
Aber es fanden sich ja neue Sachen, dann haben wir alle irgendwie diese Foren
benutzt mit irgendwelchen PHP.
PHP, BB.
Ich hab's über welche programmiert.
Ich bin schuld.
Ja, aber dann hattest du diesen Foren-Effekt. Du fragst eine Frage,
wie geht bei dem Gerät so und so, das und das?
Benutz halt die Suche.
Nee, und dann kommt dann... Wir haben einen FHQ. Ja, ich habe aber das andere
Gerät, das ist besser, da machst du es so.
Und dann denkst du so.
Ja, schön. Aber es gab doch Foren.
Die funktioniert haben. Also nie, alle nicht für die Ewigkeit,
aber so für ein paar Jahre. Also ich habe viel Zeit versenkt in Foren.
Ja, versenken kann man die Zeit.
Nein, nein, aber auch mich gut gebildet und unterhalten für meinen persönlichen Kink.
Ja, also mittlerweile funktioniert das Juicet ja wieder relativ gut,
weil halt alle anderen woanders sind.
Wo gibt es denn noch einen Server?
Es gibt Usenet-Server. Ich meine, da geht immer noch so viel Where's drüber heutzutage.
Also ich weiß nicht, ich hatte meinen ganz lange bei der FU Berlin.
Da musste man irgendwie bezahlen dann. Und irgendwann haben sie den zugemacht.
Und seitdem habe ich kein Usenet mehr. Ja, die Unis machen das nicht mehr,
aber es gibt bezahlte Usenet-Zugänge, weil da halt immer noch enorm Where's
drüber getradet werden und Files und Movies und alles.
Also du kannst über Usenet, es gibt sogar, ach Gottchen.
Google hat das auch mal irgendwie reingesaugt in, wie heißen die Foren von Google noch?
Google Groups, ja genau. Also Google hat ja mal das Usenet-Archiv aufgekauft
und rein inkorporiert und deswegen das, was so als Google Groups dargestellt
wird, das ist ja auch wirklich eine Frechheit eigentlich, dass sie das so nennen.
Das sind halt eigentlich die Usenet-Grupps. Usenet als solches,
als Infrastruktur gibt es noch.
Es wird glaube ich zu 95% Traffic-mäßig im Wesentlichen eben so für Wares-Trading gemacht.
Es gibt auch Software, ich habe jetzt leider gerade den Namen nicht am Start.
Es gibt so Software, die man sich auf seinen Raspi oder sonst wie Server installieren kann,
den connectest du halt mit dem Usenet-Account und dann hast du irgendwie noch
eine App dazu und wenn du dann irgendeinen Film sehen willst,
dann wirfst du da sozusagen den Namen rein und dann hast du am Abend irgendwie
den Film in High-Quality irgendwie auf deiner Platte einfach aus dem,
So hier wird schon genickt, sofort hat man ihn dann sozusagen,
also weißt du auch, wie diese Software heißt, irgendwie?
Sonarada, wir liefern das noch nach. Naja.
Aber jenseits der Technik nochmal, also für die Demokratie, also dieses jeder
kann sich sein Wissen und beschaffen und kriegt Fragen auf alle Antworten, wo ist das,
warum hat das nur, Sind das nur die bösen Algorithmen, das ist ja auch immer
so ein Ding, die bösen Algorithmen, die uns mit ihrer Aufmerksamkeit in immer extremere Dinge,
die Antwort finde ich ein bisschen zu simpel.
Ja, naja, was ich schon wichtig finde ist, dass es da diesen Moment gab,
wo sich die Superreichen plötzlich die sozialen Netzwerke käuflich unter den
Nagel gekreilt haben und du gemerkt hast, okay,
hier geht es jetzt doch um politische Einflussnahme und als die sozialen Netzwerke
noch nicht Tools für politische Einflussnahme war, war noch alles vielleicht
nicht grün, aber zumindest irgendwie hellgelb.
Da gab es sozusagen nur Spam und Scam.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen auch noch so ein Effekt. Also es wird einfach,
alles wird ausgenutzt sozusagen. Jede Schwäche wird sofort ausgenutzt.
Ich bin da nicht so total pessimistisch, weil wir haben halt so ein Snapshot,
als die Welt noch irgendwie gut und stabil war.
Weil jetzt die nächste Frage ist ja, okay, was wird jetzt mit diesen ganzen
KI generierten Informationen und die werden jetzt das komplette Internet zuschwemmen
und dann weiß man überhaupt nicht mehr, was irgendwie stimmt.
Wir haben halt noch diesen Wikipedia-Wikidata-Snapshot vor KI und das ist so
Ground Truth und darauf kann man auch wieder irgendwann eine bessere Welt aufbauen.
Die kann uns keiner wegnehmen.
Von daher würde ich sagen, diese freie Information und jeder hat Zugang dazu,
das wird schon bleiben. Vielleicht gibt es noch eine Übergangsphase.
MS Pro hat noch irgendwie die These aufgestellt, es kommt jetzt ein Zeitalter,
wo Leute, die noch echte Bücher lesen, das wären so Kulte und so in so mönchsartigen Zirkeln.
Ja, wird man sich so die echte, wahre Information noch gegenseitig vorrezitieren,
weil alles andere von KI, Müll zugedreht.
Aber ich glaube, die Menschheit wird irgendwann kapieren, dass dieses Ground
Truth, was wir da mal hatten und was gut gespeichert ist auf 13.000 Servern
und nicht kaputt gemacht werden kann, davon werden wir noch zehren.
Sagt der Bibliothekar. Sagt der Bibliothekar. Wir haben die letzten 2000 Jahre
überstanden, dank Bibliotheken.
Wir werden das auch die nächsten 2000 Jahre schaffen. Da bin ich in der Tat optimistisch.
Okay, gut.
Da will ich gar nichts dagegen sagen, nicht, dass das jetzt hier so eine Doomsday-Veranstaltung wird.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Das war's.
Das war meine Frage.
Okay, super.
Robert, dann haben wir sie beantwortet.
Ihr wart hilfreich. Ich nehme es mit und bewege es in meinem Herzen.
So, ewiger September 93 war es in der Tat. Das war genau diese A-Geschichte hier.
Sagt mir die KI-Zusammenfassung von Google. Okay.
Na, dann wird es ja stimmen.
Dann wird es wohl stimmen.
Dann suchen wir nach imminent death of the net predicted. Imminent.
Genau.
So, wir haben noch Zeit für einen letzten Gast, glaube ich. Dann müssen wir hier abräumen.
Wer meldet sich freiwillig? Wer wird dazu gezwungen? Das ist nämlich dann so die Alternative.
Ach, du zeigst es dann einfach ins Publikum?
Ja, sonst suche ich mir einfach jemanden aus.
Wir schmeißen so eine kleine Flasche und wer aussagt, muss auf die Bühne?
Da hinten haben wir eine Hand.
Oh, sehr gut.
Ausnahmsweise mal einen Mann.
Ja, divers.
Aber du hast ein LNP-Shirt dann. Freakshow in its best.
So, super. Applaus, Applaus.
So, wer ist denn bei uns?
Ja, moin. Ich bin Morten.
Hallo Morten.
Und ich habe eigentlich die einzig wichtige Frage mitgebracht.
Welchen Kalender verwenden wir denn 2025?
Ist ein bisschen spät für dieses Jahr.
Oder?
Du meinst 26?
Also grundsätzlich. Auch für die Zukunft.
Ich meine eher welche Software. Haben wir inzwischen Wochen jemanden zu klären?
Das Problem ist ja lange gelöst. Das ist so ein stehendes Meme hier,
der Freakshow. Ich weiß gar nicht so ganz genau, warum sich noch alle so darüber aufregen.
Weil sich Leute erinnern können.
Ja, woran eigentlich genau?
An all die unzähligen Sendungen.
Ich habe nur gesagt, das ist scheiße und es stinkt. und danach hat Apple eingelenkt.
Ich meine, das muss man ja auch mal anerkennen, oder?
Also ich würde es auch keinen aufregen.
Welche Kalender-Software verwendest du denn?
Apple-Standard-Kalender.
Aha, okay. Und bist du glücklich damit?
Die Antwort auf sowas ist immer nein. Man ist immer unzufrieden und hat immer was zu meckern.
Ja, ich benutze tatsächlich so viel Kalender.
Das ist ganz gut.
Lebst in den Tag hinein.
Okay, aber du bist so ein Macintosh-Nerd.
Was machst du denn so normalerweise mit deinem Computer?
Inzwischen bin ich auch in der Software-Infektion gelandet.
Ah, so einer. Das ist ja hier selten wie auch.
Ja, wobei ich da eher auch so eine bewegte Vergangenheit habe.
Also ich habe da mal so ein abgebrochtes Informatikstudium.
Das ist eher der Klassiker.
Das ist das Qualitätssiegel.
Genau, aber habe dann gedacht, naja gut, dann mache ich halt Basteln und Malen
und habe Design studiert in München, Fotodesign und habe zehn Jahre Freelance,
der Werbekatalog, Fotografie irgendwie mich bewegt.
Und als Corona kam, war irgendwie nicht mehr so viel mit Reisen und mit,
wir wechseln das Team alle drei Tage und so Geschichten.
Und naja, irgendwie muss man seine Familie ernähren, das machst du jetzt.
Und ja gut, dann war irgendwie ein Kumpel von mir, ja code doch wieder,
zehn Jahre nicht gemacht und habe dann mich herangesetzt, tatsächlich ein Coding
Bootcamp dann noch gemacht, drei Monate und inzwischen seit fünf Jahren als
Softwareentwickler tätig.
Welche Programmiersprache haben Sie denn übergeholfen?
Typescript die meiste Zeit. Also ich mache viel Frontend, Typescript mit React.
Mache inzwischen auch C-Sharp.
Aber nachdem ich aus dem Design komme, Sagt das E-Wort, dann ist immer noch kein Elixier. Nee, nee.
Sagt das E-Wort, dann ist er zufrieden.
Ein bisschen FOMO ist da, muss ich sagen, ist mir mal anzugucken,
aber mit Familie und Kindern, die auch hier im Kidspace irgendwie rumhocken
und so, ist Zeit halt, also ich brauche keinen Kalender, aber ich eh keine Zeit habe.
Genau, ich habe siebenjährige Zwillinge. Das macht das Leben nicht so viel einfacher.
Und insofern ist halt so, vor allen Dingen das, was man auf der Arbeit macht,
dann versucht man mal ein Projekt irgendwie, aber am Ende bleibt wenig Zeit über.
Aber genau, aber gar durch den Design-Background, ich fühle mich im Frontend
teilweise ganz wohl. Aber ich verstehe total den Hang, klare Aufgaben zu haben,
die man Frontendländer oft nicht hat.
Ja, das ist eine wilde Reise, die man da antreten muss jedes Mal.
Aber wir sind zum Glück ein sehr kleines Team von drei Leuten,
wo wir uns da schnell im Konsent haben.
Und man eher Freiheit hat, als dass jetzt zehn Leute alle reinquatschen.
Der Radius vom Button sollte aber vier Pixel sein, nicht drei.
Das könnte noch schlimmer sein.
Auf deine Frage, ich bin jetzt irgendwie sehr leise, hört mich noch irgendjemand hier?
Okay, auf deine Frage, so welcher Kalender, wenn man sagt, okay,
das Problem ist gelöst, ich habe hier was, bin ich ein paar Wochen vorausgestolpert, was vielleicht,
das ein oder andere Aha-Erlebnis nochmal produzieren könnte.
Und zwar, du hast gerade gesagt Aufgaben.
Wusstet ihr, dass man in den macOS-Erinnerungen einen Kanban-Modus einschalten kann?
Ja, aber ich habe ihn noch nicht verwendet.
Das kann ich mal kurz präsentieren. Das heißt also, ihr kennt Erinnerungen von
macOS, wo man da so Aufgaben runteinander schreiben kann.
Und da kann man dann ja solche Gruppen bilden, so Zwischenüberschriften.
Also ich habe jetzt hier mal eine Einkaufenliste und dann habe ich Milchprodukte,
Haushaltsartikel, Weinbier-Spiritosen und so weiter.
Das macht er auch hervorragend.
Stimmt, der hat jetzt auch so
eine KI drin, dass er das irgendwie so ein bisschen vorsortiert und sowas.
So und jetzt kann man unter Darstellung hingehen und sagen, ich will das nicht
als Liste haben, sondern ich will das als Spalte haben.
Und dann, tada, hat man plötzlich ein Can-Board oder ein Scrum-Board vor sich,
wo plötzlich man verschiedene Spalten hat, wo dann die Einzeltasks unten drunter sind.
Jetzt kann ich einfach hingehen und wie man das in solchen Boards so macht,
plötzlich die Tasks so von einer in die nächste Spalte reinschieben.
Den Müllbeutel zum Milchprodukt machen.
Den Milchbeutel, ja, aber you get the idea. Du kannst es also von To-Do in Arbeit erledigt,
einfach dir ein klassisches Ekan-Board bauen und brauchst keine extra Software
und synkt über alle deine Apple-Devices inklusive WebView und so weiter.
Kann mal nützlich sein, wenn man schnell und schmutzig sein Board braucht.
Mach den mal wieder zurück, das triggert mich.
Dann solltest du nicht die Autosontierfunktion.
Da kommt der Müllbeutel wieder zu Hause als Antikett.
Sehr gut.
So, also vielleicht nimmst du das.
Die Welt ist wieder in Ordnung.
Das könnt ihr mal probieren, das ist cool.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich weiß nicht, wie oft ich in meinem Leben schon versucht
habe, mich an To-Do-Apps zu gewöhnen. Das gelingt mir einfach nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das so fundamental anders geht, aber jegliche To-Do, ist komisch, ne?
To-Do-App ist immer so das Default-Programmierbeispiel.
So hier neue Programmiersprache, so machst du eine To-Do-App.
Wer braucht denn das eigentlich? Benutzt doch keiner.
Du hast zu wenig To-Dos.
Tim. Ich benutze es vor allen Dingen, um zu solchen Veranstaltungen wie dieser hier zu packen.
Da gibt es dann halt so diese Kongress-Camp-To-Do-Liste, wo ich alles abhake.
Entweder ich habe es eingepackt oder ich nehme es sowieso nicht mit,
dann ist alles abgehakt.
Und wenn dann alles geschehen ist, kann ich alles wieder enthaken und für die
nächste Veranstaltung sind die ganzen To-Dos wieder da.
Ich räume ein, dass wenn man so eine Deadline hat, dann funktioniert sowas.
aber für so eternal tasks ist das ja einfach nur so, weiß ich nicht.
Eternal to do's, die bleiben dann da.
Es werden immer mehr und es wird immer deprimierender.
Genau.
Aber terminierte To-Dos sind halt
ganz gut, wenn man seinen Kalender mit irgendwas nicht vollmüllen will.
Also zum Beispiel wirklich was einmal und was jetzt nicht ein Kalenderereignis ist.
Ja schon, aber irgendwann ist so der Punkt, wo dann steht in der To-Do-Liste
Schornsteinfeger anrufen und dann kommst du auf dieses To-Do und denkst dir,
du hast seit zwei Jahren eine Wärmepumpe.
Aber eigentlich müsste alles in den Kalender, weil auch dieses,
für mich, ich finde ja immer diese Metainformation, wann hat man eigentlich
ein To-Do erstellt und wann hat man es auch erledigt, ist ja auch eine Information
und ich sehne mich immer danach,
mal so ein komplettes Log-File zu haben, weil man ja daraus eine ganze Menge
interessante Informationen ableiten kann, weil manchmal starre ich,
ich komm immer wieder mit neuen To-Do-Listen, man probiert ja immer was Neues
aus und dann so, oh, eine To-Do-List von 1998.
Was habe ich denn da alles nicht getan?
Visual Basic lernen.
Manchmal würde es einfach helfen, wann wurde denn dieser Eintrag überhaupt erzeugt.
Also das wäre einfach, wir brauchen mehr Metadaten. Das ist ein echtes Thema.
Ja, aber am Ende frustriert das halt auch so ewig. Also wir setzen halt Kanboard
ein bei uns in diversen Zusammenhängen und da sind auch solche Alternatismen Und so,
wenn dieses Ticket irgendwie nicht binnen 200 Tagen angefasst worden ist,
dann ändert sich die Farbe in rot. Alle möglichen Eskalationsstufen.
Das hilft doch auch alles nichts.
Du hast dann halt hinterher trotzdem eine Spalte mit irgendwie 50 Einträgen
und alle sind tiefrot und alle sind frustriert, weil nichts geht vor.
Und dann gibt es ja wieder, ja du machst es ja auch falsch.
Du musst die Spalte so konfigurieren, dass nur fünf Items überhaupt rein dürfen.
Aber so funktioniert die Arbeitswelt halt. Und zumindest meine nicht.
Und dann am Ende sind alle immer nur traurig und gucken sich Betroffene an.
Und die Gefahr ist ja auch, dass es tatsächlich Druck und Stress aufbaut, also,
Also, wenn das terminiert, also so meine Erfahrung ist, irgendwann,
also wenn es zu stark getrieben wird, dann gibt das einfach so einen Druck und
das ist dann einfach scheiße. Also man will nicht unter Druck arbeiten.
Du musst es wie bei Wikis machen. Du musst es wie bei Wikis machen.
Da ist es ja so, irgendwann ist dein Wiki in einem Zustand, dass du dann das
Wikisystem wechselst zu einem neuen Wikisystem und ein neues Wiki anfängst.
So änderst du halt dein To-Do-Listen-System und fängst eine neue To-Do-Liste an.
Tja, das ganze Leben ist nicht mehr ein Quiz, sondern ein Wiki.
Ich habe neulich die These gehört, dass wenn man wirklich was erledigt haben
möchte, dann kann man das eigentlich nur mit Bewegung lösen.
Also sozusagen, also der Körper entscheidet innerhalb oder der Kopf lässt dieses,
ich müsste jetzt etwas tun,
wenn du dem nicht, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was der Zeitraum war,
aber so irgendwie sowas, wenn du nicht in den ersten fünf Sekunden darauf eine Reaktion zeigst.
Mit deinem Körper.
Mit deinem ganzen Körper. Also wenn du es nicht in fünf Sekunden beginnst,
dann wirst du es nicht tun.
Wobei das Beginnen nicht heißt, sofort unbedingt es auch gleich zu tun,
aber du kannst dem dadurch nachhelfen, indem du deinen Körper in Bewegung setzt,
also aufstehst, irgendwo hingehst.
Weil dann der Körper dadurch sensorisch aktiviert wird mit diesem Task und du
in diesem, ich tue jetzt das, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
Also weg, man steht auf und geht weg von dem Computer, den man braucht,
um den Task zu erledigen.
Das macht total Sinn.
Das sind diese Zustandsänderungen.
Also es klingt so ein bisschen nach, does this to do spark joy? Also das ist so.
Ich habe jetzt mal nur so eine steile These in den Raum gestellt.
Ja, Zustandsänderung sagt man bei Kindern ja auch, soll helfen,
wenn die sich, wenn die ausflippen oder so, einfach so das ganze Setting ändern,
irgendwo anders hinbringen oder irgendein ganz anderes Thema oder eine Süßigkeit
in die Haare, irgendwas machen, was halt den Grundzustand verändert und dann
passiert quasi ein kleiner Reset.
Ja, nur ein Kontextwechsel.
Morten, den machen wir jetzt bei dir auch. Vielen Dank für das Dasein.
Wir müssen nämlich jetzt hier auch in den letzten drei Minuten die Sendung zu Ende bringen.
Ja, ich würde sagen, damit sind wir so gut wie am Ende der Sendung angekommen.
Haben wir noch ein paar letzte Worte?
Schön ist es hier wieder.
Schön ist es wieder hier.
Ja, schön ist es. Ich muss aufs Klo. Aber nee, eigentlich nicht.
Roddy trinkt wirklich langsam Bier.
Ja, du kannst da gleich für die nächste Session auch noch bleiben,
bis du dein Bier ausgetrunken hast.
Was ist denn als nächstes?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, aber die werden es ja dann...
Die kehren mich doch von der Bühne.
Weiß ich nicht. Guck mal mal ins Programm.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay. Also ihr habt keine weiteren Anmerkungen? Nö.
Das gibt mir die Gelegenheit, hier das Outro anzuschmeißen und sozusagen allen
das Gefühl zu geben, dass es das war mit der Freakshow Nummer 301.
Ich finde, das war eine richtige Freakshow.
Jetzt mal mit so...
Hey Tim, ich glaube, es hat nett schon geklingelt.
Diese Konditionierung, Gott, wenn mir noch Jahre fehlen hat.
Alright, tschüss, danke, das war's.